oh
[Applause]
please welcome
kevin smith and mark bernardin for fat
man beyond
hey
hello
welcome to fat man beyond i'm kevin
smith i'm mark bernard
los angeles out and about and doing
stuff and stuff very [ __ ] cool i
can't believe there are this many people
here man you're all [ __ ] suicidal
uh but we gather together for such an
important reason i guess it's worth a
risk getting health how are you feeling
speaking of health i feel strong
yes
yeah because it's [ __ ] inspiring dude
well i mean it's mostly false
but i mean i feel okay a projection of
strength yeah i mean strong is a thing
i've been felt in like 30 years
but i feel good
i was um driving here this is apropos
another
but i was driving here and uh
because i listened to a lot of uh yacht
rock slash dad rock i uh
billy joel was on the [ __ ]
player yeah [ __ ] billy joel i mean i
know some people like look at billy joel
i grew up with billy joel and i what i
was thinking tonight
because i was listening to my life as i
was driving here
was
like that song probably had a deep
[ __ ] influence
in who i eventually became because at a
young age like on the radio and all
throughout my house once they got the
record and [ __ ]
you heard this [ __ ] story song about
people who are like [ __ ] it and just you
know went and lived a dream or something
like that
wound up in my dna man which is kind of
nuts because my people don't have that
i didn't come from people that are like
let's dream they were all like oh [ __ ]
let's [ __ ] that's as good as it gets
and [ __ ] they did you know lots of
[ __ ] but not a lot of dreaming and
[ __ ] a lot of people that just like did
jobs and not saying like doing a job's
bad thing we all do a job sooner or
later but like nobody was ever like i'm
gonna go into business for myself or
something like that everyone just worked
for somebody else and whatnot so
i think listening to that song over and
over in childhood like really implanted
an idea that like oh there's a different
way to be
not just the way you see all around you
and stuff like that but like is a story
about a [ __ ] cat who just like
chucked it all and went do stand-up
comedy on the west coast and [ __ ] you're
like that's a possibility and whatnot
forgive me i just smoke a huge joint in
the back
so i'm piecing [ __ ] together but i don't
know it was kind of beautiful moment
where i was like i owe [ __ ] billy
joel more than i know
especially because he was not new
jersey's poet laureate the way he was
long island's poet laureate you had your
own yeah you would imagine that like
springsteen would do more but his songs
were all about getting out like get the
[ __ ] out of jersey
gotta go man [ __ ] thunder rode the
[ __ ] out of here and [ __ ] and i didn't
feel that way i love new jersey so i was
never like yeah man i gotta get the [ __ ]
out of this one horse town i was like i
want to be here this is great [ __ ]
one horse town means like no competition
this rocks
so yeah i didn't his music which i love
don't get me wrong but that [ __ ] like is
not necessarily in my dna
billy jones yeah despite the fact that
one of his biggest songs was literally
called moving out
oh my god that was [ __ ] like so well
analyzed and
how like how long were you you just
stopped listening to me
and started going through the billy joel
[ __ ] sound catalog to be like how can
i take his joy away yes uh italian
restaurant i think that's the wrong one
um yeah down easter alexa i don't know
if that means anything to him um i know
this is really off brand for the show
but anyway that's how we're getting
started tonight and you're stoned and
have a weird flat of fancies off-brand
for these shows
very very true the billy joel of it all
though can you can you think of any
billy joel connection to genre at
all uh
other than the video for uptown girl
which is a [ __ ] fantasy for sure
um
what what
say goodbye to hollywood
never um
yeah i mean yeah it's very quasi
futuristic right and [ __ ] it's about
everything collapsing i mean we didn't
start the fire as like a season of
doctor who
just this weird time travel thing
through all of the worst parts of
it's appropriate your name is bernardin
because you are on fire tonight my
friend
um and tonight ladies and gentlemen we
are live last well we're always live
when we do the show but last week we
were doing it from our homes and whatnot
tonight as you can hear and probably see
as they zoom the camera around from the
place place andrew will give you shots
show you there are human beings in this
place and this place
[Applause]
this place is the scum and villainy
cantina in hollywood right on hollywood
boulevard man uh one of the
best places in the world to get drunk if
you're very nerdy uh
no worries here about getting into a bar
fight unless that bar fight is just like
star trek star wars
and then they turn it into a musical and
[ __ ]
flash dance breaks out
pretty impressive place man so if you're
ever in town uh come visit us right here
at uh the scum and villainy cantina even
if we're not doing a show
uh they're always selling booze isn't
that right uh banff man pop in and bam
oh look at him it's jc ladies and
gentlemen proprietor this here cantina
give it up for it
i uh i actually have a funny story about
that the [ __ ] there was a a scuffle a
couple weeks back
and the scuffle i just andrew back to me
i just [ __ ] told them
it's a safe space and you're just like
no it's dangerous well just like a star
wars movie the scuffle was was cute
they got in a scuffle over
which hogwarts houses different star
wars characters would belong to
and he got heated
so more of a debate not a real fight
somebody lost an arm though yeah one guy
in a cantina it never happens did anyone
throw hands
one guy grabbed another guy's shirt
that is pretty [ __ ]
a hufflepuff because those [ __ ]
no that's pure slytherin right there man
like when you're losing you're just like
bartholomew no man you sleep on a
hufflepuff they will shoot a [ __ ]
you're right we got to watch those
hufflepuffers
um wow man what do you do in that
instance do you throw them out the bar
we did
you can't you can't look you don't [ __ ]
around i mean
look i appreciate the passion but you
can't you can't touch anything [ __ ]
back pedal these people you look right
in the eye of the [ __ ] camera and you
say here at [ __ ] scum and villainy
[ __ ] around and find out
i'm sure that'll be
that'll be so good for business
people like he seems mean i'll drink
down the street i'll take my chances at
another watering hole
we don't serve your kind here
[Applause]
brian there you go
enough about billy joel back to star
wars
um all right we got uh a lot to do do we
have ads or no we got one ad which we
can do later we could do later good um
not because we don't want to get to the
sponsor as soon as possible
we love our sponsors uh but we have a
guest
to get to and our guest is on the east
coast
so he's staying awake just to do this uh
as you all know we start the show
eightish
[Music]
on the west coast but you know that's
like 11 30 in new york or back in jersey
and you know who knows what the [ __ ]
time it is in england someone do the
math but early
yeah early oh speaking of which uh
because i'm like do the math and a bunch
of people in chat would be writing [ __ ]
if you don't see chat uh it's not
because we turned it off uh it's because
there seems to be a youtube issue
before i come to the show i was just
youtubing while i was like home and [ __ ]
just kind of looking at news and [ __ ] in
case there was anything i might have
missed and i couldn't call youtube up
i could call anything else up but not
[ __ ] youtube so i was like oh it must
be them and then when i i finally was
able to call it up jc though says that
before we went we're a little bit late
not because of me but because there was
a tech issue and the tech issue included
that the chat box wouldn't come up
yeah i can't get any the video will load
on youtube but none of the
like could no chat no like videos you
might like no upvote no down vote but we
are streaming on youtube we are
streaming on youtube we're just but we
can't confirm it somehow unless somebody
watching on youtube texts us at
three tooth notes
what's the what's the is there a phone
for the bar
yeah but it's like it just goes to
voicemail
does anybody have a phone number we can
throw out there to the world sender even
i mean
anybody
does anybody know somebody at home
watching on youtube
i would love to say like well my wife is
watching but that never happens
it's working
we got comments
chat is loading are there comments
oh the comments are back oh good i bet
you all the comments are like you
[ __ ] idiots the comments are on
get to your guest which we shall anyway
enough about all that we have a guest
who's waiting in a different time zone
[ __ ] is talking to us from the
future man that's how good this show is
we grab people from the goddamn [ __ ]
future um and uh he's here to talk about
uh
well october to you and me but scott
tober yes to everybody else ladies and
gentlemen
welcome to uh fat man beyond live
probably from his home on the east coast
man give it up for scott snyder
oh [ __ ] he's back he's right there he's
everywhere
how are you doing sir
i'm great it's good to see you again and
mark excellent to see you the last time
i saw you
like five years ago or so that was a
damn minute ago
um tell us about scott tobe we're gonna
try to get this all out of you before
you fall asleep on us and [ __ ]
uh tell us about scott tober man this is
awesome first off um you're you're still
at dc and you're still
loving working at dc correct
well i i still love dc and i i love
working there but i'm taking time off to
do this is that right so so you're not
doing them uh
side by side when did you stop what was
your last dc script that you submitted
it was uh our big event that we did uh
just it ended in january called dc death
metal so it was like a big extravaganza
that was like
bunkers crazy [ __ ]
now you've been like the dc golden boy
for such a long time now was it scary to
be like i'm just gonna stop
for a minute you know what i'm saying
like sometimes you step out of it and
then the new golden kid shows up and
suddenly people are like [ __ ] your
batman and [ __ ] like that can't imagine
it ever happens to you
and then
take some time to make my own stuff and
so it's all like they're all books that
i've been working on on the side with
you know my favorite creators and
friends and um comixology uh which i
know mark has a great book out over
there called adora in the distance which
i can't say enough good things about oh
thank you but comixology which is like
the big digital platform for all comics
they came along and they asked me what i
was working on and i said i have these
books and they took all of them so they
took eight books and we have um three
coming out in october right now one is
with greg capullo and it's called we
have demons it's a big over-the-top like
90s style kind of gore-fest fun greg
capullo now correct me if i'm wrong this
is the first time you've ever worked
with that famous artist is that correct
yeah he's it's our first time ever doing
a create our own book together which is
a thrill you know we love doing batman
and uh it was a dream job for a long
time and then doing metal and death
metal and everything but we don't own
any of it you know so
dc has always been kind to us and sent
me like the joker lawn statues and the
the you know the masks and everything
and uh
but um to have something that's ours
it's a whole other thrill as i'm sure
you guys know you know is there like um
you know
you've been uh working so long over at
dc is there anything most of the stuff
you were playing with with their toys
but you brought a lot to both of you
brought a lot to the table as well are
there any concepts or characters that
you're ever like [ __ ] i wish i had saved
that
for me
oh yeah i mean it's more like there's so
many things i'd still love to do you
know i mean there's so many characters
i'd love to write you know uh
green lantern and aquaman and all that
kind of stuff but
yeah my i it really was just a matter of
like the pandemic putting things in
perspective and being like you're
getting older and you want to try your
own stuff for a bit so
yeah we have um we got eight books
coming out over two years and they start
to span the whole range from like big
summer blockbuster stuff to smaller real
dark horror westerns everything so
yeah we're real we're real excited about
it and thrilled and they gave it a name
as shameless as scott tober and i was
like you know what you live once i'll
invite my parents to the party let's do
it
and uh i just sort of leaned in i was
like i was juggling bear on the unicycle
for dc because i love the stuff we did
there i might as well be one for myself
[ __ ] yeah man god damn you're the
captain of your own ship at this point
well done the um when when you
uh launched the books you just mentioned
two years
so is this you going all in on
creator-owned stuff
solely for two years like you know
you're not going to work anyplace else
pretty much i mean you know i really i i
gave it one year but it's been going
well and i feel like you know i i'd like
to keep it up for another year i mean
we've got like this book nocterra over
at image that's like you know a darkness
envelops the earth and changes everybody
into monsters and then we got yeah we
have demons and and uh and clear which
is out today the sci-fi thriller all
these different things and i don't know
once i started doing it for myself it
just
it feels so liberating you know and all
these things that you realize we're you
didn't you didn't see we're stressing
you out you suddenly realize we're
taking up so much of your energy but i'm
sure it's the same way for a lot of
people like you know you come out of the
pandemic and you just reevaluate you're
like you know what
i want to be more my own person do more
my own thing and um i love marvel i love
dc i'm sure i'll i have like plenty of
stories in my head for dc characters and
marvel characters from punisher to
wolverine to everybody but
i just it was like take this time see if
it works and um yeah so far it's been
it's been going really well i feel
really lucky
i mean you you probably had like the
keys to the comic kingdom were yours you
could have taken these books anywhere
why why comixology why were they the
right home for these what an excellent
[ __ ] question man that's a great
[ __ ] question god your questions are
so good you could have [ __ ] literally
gone anywhere [ __ ] throwing your
scott snyder son of zack snyder dick on
a table and [ __ ]
and been like this is where i want to do
my job and they'd be like oh my god come
in why comixology and what's the setup
there are there digital is there ever a
paper edition
there is yeah and it's dude i get the
zack snyder thing i like every day to
this day i get like everyone thinks i'm
zack snyder all the time
you just give in and you're like this is
why i did that in justice league
do you take do you take a lot of do you
take a lot of [ __ ] for the snyder cut
i do but i like fight back a lot of the
time i just make [ __ ] up you know where
you're like well i made that creative
decision because blah blah blah you know
kryptonians should kill people like that
and whatever are you sure you left dc
are you sure you left dc and they didn't
ask you to [ __ ] leave i know right i
know no they they're they've been super
they they're great and i mean i love i
love the people over there and um i just
we just had this big comicsology party
and half of them came so it was fun like
they we're all friends you know marvel
dc all that rivalry is [ __ ] i mean
you know you don't get into comics to
make money or to to be competitive
[ __ ] you mean you only like you just
get into it because you love this weird
medium but comixology like your question
mark i i'm really glad you asked like
it really was you know during the
pandemic i had planned on putting out
the books at different places and some
you know most of them in print some of
them digital first and i was going to
experiment with them but
what i realized was that
one of the things that that was scary
during the pen when everything shut down
in the comic industry like everywhere
else was
the spookiness of how closed it really
seemed like that it you know might not
open on the other side because of all
these systemic problems with shipping
and with distribution and speculation
all these things that are you know
rabbit holes to go down for a talk like
this but what it made me think about was
just the way my kids consume
entertainment the way
so many industries have kind of moved
forward to do browsing through digital
you buy physical for collectible you
know what i mean and how many how many
fields like indie books for example are
having this big boom right now because
people rediscovered reading digitally
audible that and then they go and want
the book um my comic store here fourth
world i've been going to before i broke
in they're having a banner year and a
lot of it is people that read online and
then come in to buy the physical so i
was like you know to make our books
affordable for people going through a
hard time we'll do a subscription based
thing so you pay 5.99 to comixology a
month you get all of our books you know
we do three a month um three series a
month for that one price and on top of
that you have access to like
all of these amazing books like marks
and other people that are um doing new
stuff but also all the classics that
made me want to write i know you love
kevin like dark knight returns and
sandman and you know all that stuff is
free on there too with a subscription so
i was like let's do this and then the
great thing was they had just signed a
deal with dark horse comics which
publishes hellboy and
frank miller stuff a lot of other great
books um and they were like well the
books will also come out in print six
months later and we can do them in
whatever format fits the direct market
so like we have demons which is like a
big ass you know over the top you know
girl with a robot arm slashing demons
with like you know saturday morning
cartoon but r-rated
kind of book like that book we're gonna
do um in a format that fits the direct
market single issue you know variant
covers that stuff and other books that
make more sense to do his trades will do
that way so again the whole thing was
about like how do we do something that
says
let's keep the books affordable let's
show the ways that print and digital can
work together as opposed to being
competitive because again not to go down
such a geek rabbit hole with it but i
really believe that one of the things
holding the comics industry back is that
digital has been kind of held to this
position where everything has to be the
same price the same content released on
the same day
all of that stuff as opposed to being
like a cheaper more immersive version
but then you go to the store and buy for
the bigger collectible experience
so anyway that's that's that's my
thinking you know and that's why i went
to all the co-creators on the books greg
capullo and francis manipal and jock and
everybody and i'm like what do you guys
think and they all
sort of felt the same way i did so we
went with it and we still have books in
the direct market straight like nocterra
and undiscovered country but we felt
like this was a way of saying to people
the books are affordable and you can
fall in love with comics all over again
by getting a subscription and also you
can go get them in the store and
hopefully it'll
get you thinking about ways of um
falling you know just falling in love
with comics all over again in both
formats
[ __ ] beautiful man give it up for
scout so well put
[Applause]
um scott how many books are out already
so two are out we're releasing three
this month last tuesday we did we have
demons which again is like it's about a
young girl who discovers her father was
like not just this boring guy but it was
a it's like my fantasy for my kids to
discover that i'm not just this boring
[ __ ] but like
the the the she discovers her father is
like the indiana jones of demon slayers
and and it's a lot of fun
uh this week like today the second book
came out they come out every tuesday so
every tuesday this month something comes
out from us so we have demons number one
was last week clear number one is today
it's a sci-fi thriller about a near
future where everybody connects the
internet neurologically and the whole
thing that everybody does is they skin
the world however they want so like the
superstructure legally has to stay the
same but if you want to look out and see
like manga filter or porn filter or
zombie apocalypse filter you see it that
way and um or you know we lost this war
we won this war filter
that and it's about a detective who's
solving a murder mystery in this world
and he always keeps his setting on clear
as you can imagine it's like a visual
buffet for francis menopause who's a you
know superstar uh and good friend to be
able to draw like any [ __ ] thing he
wants in it um and then next week knight
of the ghoul comes out which is a
straight up in the middle horror it's
about like a lost great horror film from
the 30s called knight of the ghoul
it was destroyed in the studio fire that
killed all these people and this guy
who's kind of a down on his luck uh
wannabe filmmaker discovers the pieces
and then tracks down the writer director
who's in a hospice care in this like
rest home in the middle of nowhere
california desert and the book is like
an intertwined set of two like a double
helix structure where it's like one part
of the story is the remnants of the old
film done in black and white by
francesco franco villa and the other
half is in color and it's him getting to
the bottom of what happened and he
starts to realize the monster from the
film is real and it's in this building
and it's going to kill all of them
so it's a lot of fun and uh yeah there
are five more coming you know as soon as
these three are done so the goal was to
just be like
make our make our books i mean i'd
probably serve us better to do like go
out and buy each one individually but i
genuinely believe between this and doing
the comic teaching i'm doing now that
at this phase in my career the better
thing is to try and make people fall in
love with comics make their own comics
you know get into reading comics in the
most affordable and immersive way
possible
and uh that's what we're trying to do
with this so that's that's my hope you
know that it works out in that way and
it just expands the audience you know i
see the way my kids consume stuff and i
feel like comics has been held in this
way where you know print again is sort
of like uh seen as as competitive with
digital where you know if everything's
the same price same content and i don't
feel like going to the store one day i
buy it digitally but if it's 99 cents to
get a cheaper smaller version of the
digital and i like it i'll go buy the
print you know i'll buy them both
so that's i don't know that's what i
that's my belief about it and what i
hope is hope is true and will strengthen
the you know health and the industry on
the other side of all this
tell me about the the teaching because
you've been doing a lot of sort of
writer's classes and writer's workshops
where did that desire come from oh it's
always been there uh mark thanks again
yeah for asking like uh
i've been teaching since uh i uh i you
know graduated
school and i was teaching comics before
i even broke in so
uh and i've been lucky enough to have
students that i'm sure like i learned
more from them than they did for me but
you know james tynen and uh
and uh uh
you know um vita ayala and marguerite
bennett and phil kennedy johnson who's
on action and mike maurici who's on
uh the plot and barbaric and and a lot
of people matt rosenberg so it's it's
i've been really lucky to have amazing
people pass through
and for me greg kapoor always teases me
he's like you're training your [ __ ]
replacement kid why are you doing that
and i'm always like no if i do my job
right you know
the it's the opposite i'm helping them
be who they who they're gonna be
and it's not competitive at all it's
showing them how to sort of use all
these tools in their own way to to
express their voice you know in their
own unique singular way
so it keeps me young also i feel like an
[ __ ] if i teach them
write your own favorite story you know
every day or or you know write stuff
you're passionate about and then i don't
go home and do the same thing
so it you know it keeps me honest keeps
me young i love it and so i'm doing it
through um sub stack right now we got a
deal with sub stack where they were like
do you want to come on and make comics
and i was just sort of like you know i
don't i don't really want to make comics
on there right now
but uh i'll teach and uh so yeah we do a
live class from my comic shop
uh out here the my local shop um fourth
world uh once a month
seven bucks a month and it's like comic
writing 101 it's for beginners
uh pros like anybody and it's
interdisciplinary so i bring in stuff
from like
you know screenwriting and fiction
writing and all that so it's a lot of
fun i love it um and if you sign up you
know you can see all the classes you
missed
uh in video and they're all archived in
that so it's a work in progress like
it's totally experimental and a little
bit rough around the edges but it's
that's the fun of it it's there and the
guys bust my balls in the shop and
all of that while we go and someone will
walk in after it's closed to buy [ __ ]
while i'm you know knock my stuff over
so i enjoy it because it's just you know
us doing our thing and no pressure you
got your own master class look at you
it's fun it's a lot of fun man i i
really
i love it i mean i really feel like it's
been inspiring in a dark time to see
so many people fall in love with their
geek you know childhood loves all over
again
comics and you know role playing and and
uh and and video games but all this
stuff like that falling into the whole
story systems of them that way and with
comics like you see this boom in shops
right now and you just want to keep it
going you know however
it doesn't always mean just making more
physical comics i feel like it means
making a healthier bigger industry that
invites people in however
you know i hate people i hate the idea
of being like well you're not a real fan
if you know you're not a real fan if you
don't do this or read that i'm like if
you ever liked one page of a comic once
then you're a comic fan
and you're welcome and i hope you i hope
you enjoy it and come on in the water is
great
ah give it up man that's beautiful
i imagine it's a different world of uh
feedback now like when you're working on
batman that's a character everyone's got
[ __ ] feelings about and opinions
about and ideas about what they like
when you're launching your own stuff
like you're not up against it you're not
being compared to
previous people or even your previous
you know iterations of that character
and stuff is there some freedom
from like uh not like the trolls but
freedom from anybody any
fear of feedback
oh man it's that's you're so right like
i mean i i got used to it but you at
first you take it so personally you
realize just
when you're on batman i mean and
everyone will be like and sometimes it's
funny like when you're i was on dick
grayson as batman for a while and i was
trying to write this really personal
story and everybody just wanted more of
shirtless or ass shots all the time and
they would write me and just be like you
know he's never he's never shirtless
you're never giving any butt shots of
him i'm like this is a very serious
story you know what i mean and then by
the end you're just like he's fighting
shirtless you know
camera close-up on his butt the whole
time whatever
because you realize like the the whole
thing is like if you you accept the fact
that they're just passionate about the
characters in their own way and
sometimes they'll hate what you're doing
and you i told every you know everybody
who's been on batman since me
i'm friendly with and i always had the
same talk with them and be like
and it's kind of what grant told me
grant morrison when i started and i was
terrified and i bumped into him in san
diego and he saw that i was like shaking
in my boots and he was just like
you got to make your version of birth
and a death and don't worry it's your
you know him better than anybody because
if you think about it as batman there's
always someone that's going to know it
better than you that has a better take
in their own way or knows the continuity
differently and it's true like they'll
you have the bat cat fans like that if
he's not with catwoman hate your guts
you have the uh non catwoman for you the
poison ivy fans who have poison ivy's a
villain hate you if she's a hero you
know other fans hate you like there's
there's no winning it so you have to
just kind of be like this is my version
horse blinders on
and i'm writing fan fiction for myself
and nobody's reading it that was how i
got through it because i it scared me to
death where i'd have like all these you
know panic attacks when i'm like
batman 100 plus thousand people read it
and you just picture like two yankee
stadiums like one on top of the other
and you're on the mound like reading the
book to them on a microphone you know
you're like tap tap tap and you're like
panel one uh batmobile appears and
they're like
the roar of that in your ears and you're
just like oh my god i can't do this
anymore so i would yeah i could i could
easily get behind that sport though
i would buy tickets for that
you know like seasons right yeah people
reading comics in the [ __ ] field and
[ __ ] can we lay down in the field with
you while you read the comics
you know like at the end like the
emperor coliseum thing yeah no totally
it's
yeah it's a great feeling doing this on
your own because you know the character
is better than anybody because you made
them up you know and
it's a different it's a different thing
i mean i it's such an honor and a thrill
to write characters like batman or
wonder woman and superman and and i love
it and i want to do it more but um doing
something that's totally yours and
inviting people in and seeing them show
up there's there's a different joy to
that
because it's you know it's just a pure
pure connection where they're not coming
because of the legacy they're not coming
because there's 70 or 80 years of
mythology for them to choose or they
have a favorite villain or
you know whatever it is uh they're just
coming to see
with you um what you're building and
that fan connection is like you know
something really magical not to sound
corny but it's true it's very true think
about it man like when you met the
audience
you met because of batman but now the
audience for the comixology work they're
there for you they're not there for 80
years of continuity they're like we
[ __ ] like this guy we'll follow him
anywhere even to this digital app
what is it what is how do they find the
books
they're a lot of way it's easy like if
you have prime um they're free already
for you which i don't even know if i'm
supposed to say but they are like so
you can way to kill the subscriptions
man you're like you already own it
i know i just i just screwed myself out
of much money but
you have prime they're they're go read
them they're free but the best way is
probably um
if you subscribe to comixology unlimited
which again is like the price of a comic
book a month
um not just because you get all the
books for that price but because it
gives you access to
really what's like a whole library of
classic and new comics and including
marks again great comic door in the
distance with their electricity they're
so sweet um
double plug
true no i mean i mark note i read it i
read it early i i i'm friends with
ariella we're working on something
together and it's just incredible
everyone should go read it no um but
yeah the so if you go to that you
subscribe you get all of them and uh you
know we'll have it kind of goes like
this so go like october
demons one clear one ghoul one
you know november
demons two clear two gold two and so on
and so forth so you'll always be getting
more books from us than one and getting
a bargain but the real hope is that
you'll use it to find creators better
than me and
find stuff you love and go down that
rabbit hole and and just you know love
comics then go to the shop and
and uh and uh and uh find stuff for
yourself
before we let you go um
what's the name of this publishing
venture that you started and why was it
not schneider cut well they actually
like no no [ __ ] they actually at one
point they were like do you think snyder
verse is like reclaimable so i was like
no
oh my god you don't want to take those
folks on man
well no and the thing is like i have a
i've honestly like there's tons i like
about those films and i zach has been
really nice to me and i'm appreciative
of i have no no like no bones with a
snyder
uh
you know fans in that way but it's just
like my
i've been intertwined with him for so
many years of being confused for him and
then i was like oh he's my son oh no
he's my dad i don't know he's my brother
my
mom whatever like it's always just this
you know confusion
that uh
having that that was a nightmare uh idea
in my you know like that it was a that
pitch was like a no hard note
so that's where the scott tober stuff
came from um but
so my the the lion is under my my
company's call it's called best jacket
it's after my my sons jack and emmett so
jacket is a portmento of their names
then we got pregnant with a third well
after that his name is quinn my wife was
like you could call a jacket with a
queue and i was like that's way too
fancy i can't do that that's right
for like another company some other time
but yeah that's just fine let us don't
roll over that that's the most adorable
origin name of all time give it up for
scott man
how sweet
you're honoring your [ __ ] kids in the
name of your company
i couldn't do that if i wanted to
without violating another company all
together
it's a good homage though
it is a good homage um
uh let me ask you this before we let you
go because i know it's late and stuff uh
as a guy who has worked at dc and and
has worked on many many characters we're
going to be talking about in a few
minutes uh the big announcement about
the jonathan kent superman was your take
on on this did you know it was coming
yeah well i'm friends with tom taylor
he's an amazing guy amazing writer
yeah i mean my feeling is is really the
same as his which is that you know john
kent is a new character needs uh you
know a new i think like a is he's built
from the ground up to be a new kind of
superman for a new generation
and i think you know having a superman
who reflects
uh more people more people can kind of
identify with in different ways is is a
great thing you know i'm i'm proud of dc
and of of everybody there for i think
expanding
what that s shield stands for on
multiple characters you know in that way
like everybody can have the superman
that they see themselves in
that way too and i'm i think that it's a
a nice uh a nice thing and tom and the
other thing is like i know that tom as a
writer is gonna tell an amazing story
that guy is like one of the best guys in
comics and uh i love his stuff like
right to left you know on his own his
indie stuff seven secrets to his dc
stuff so
i'm confident that any story he tells is
gonna be great so i know he'll earn it
and make it amazing
beautifully put every answer you good oh
yeah everyone give it up for the amazing
the spectacular scott
[ __ ] snyder
[Applause]
thanks again guys oh thank you man
excellent seeing you scott go to sleep
scott's comics as he said available on
comicsology
right now best jacket best jacket press
that's best jacket press he didn't say
press though he just said best jacket uh
well maybe i'm adding [ __ ] i know look
at you just just one up yeah like that's
a first draft here yeah plus that [ __ ]
um what a great guy
perhaps the nicest guy in comics you
know in the running for sure yeah easily
such a good dude i'm gonna check out his
books because i do have prime
the weird thing is i have prime and i
also pay for comixology
i mean
but bezos needs the money anyway
um ah
let's see man uh should we jump into our
ad before we jump into that yeah let's
let's do that because this this show is
[ __ ] thick and we're not gonna want
to take a break
and we are not talking about anybody's
dick today yeah
we're not talking about getting hard or
getting them clean we're talking about
making them smell good
native deo oh
i was like where is this going right
do we have a department where we talk
about dicks i was like did i forget um
did i have a dick slip yes uh this show
this year's show is sponsored ladies and
gentlemen and this edition of fat man
beyond is sponsored by the good folks at
native deodorant man go to nativedeo.com
slash
something slash fat man
or use a promo code fat man at checkout
get 20 off your first order
somebody looks over your [ __ ]
shoulder as you're typing in that
address they're going to be like they're
a fetishist
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm a fetishist for smelling [ __ ]
good this native [ __ ] is amazing man
this great product so much so my wife
has it when i take a shower every day i
stare native in the [ __ ] face and i
use it
it's right there
i'm a bar soap man though like
my wife is a body wash lady what why do
what do you think there's got to be
something there right like something to
psychoanalyze why is she body washing
not a bar of soap and why aren't i body
washed what's my [ __ ] problem mark
i i don't know i just i'm trying to
break the idea of the image of you and
like a first nations dude in the shower
so just staring at native in the face
i don't know why that slipped in yeah it
must have been the body wash it could be
you threw me off because it's all
slippery
um what uh do the good folks at natives
say this time around um well they say
dear fat man beyond you're fired
it's like well this is a short answer
let's go home uh no native cares about
the products you put on your body
they're about stopping the stink the
right way
that's the native difference you
probably already know about native's
legendary aluminium-free deodorant i
said it fancy
the british pronunciation manium
mark speaks multiple languages i do
multiple accents but if you tried their
body wash toothpaste or their brand new
mineral based sunscreen the [ __ ] they
have toothpaste yes
it's news to me man they're gonna watch
fat man beyond more often they just said
yes exclamation point that was that
excitement yeah yes yes some [ __ ]
toothpaste i'll give their toothpaste a
whirl i like these cats man they make a
good product vegan as [ __ ] right um
apparently yes i you shouldn't eat it
man
one day i'm in a plane crash this is my
prediction and uh because i dream about
it all the time a dream that i'm on a
plane and the plane is always coming in
for the weirdest of [ __ ] landings
like there's skyscrapers everywhere and
the captain's like we're going to go for
this and he does some of this [ __ ]
doesn't like drunk denzel yes
yes i think that's where it comes from
i'm a rollers [ __ ]
i'm like i hope he's on coke do not ever
in your entire life think that i won't
land this plane upside down
[Applause]
um yeah i have dream land on this plane
this plane landed on us
you're doing the whole denzel i'm doing
every denzel i know but
through the prism of flight yes
i'm a man on fire
just do titles
i'm game on point oh my god today is
your training day
i hate to break up the denzel party i
hate to know we should sell some [ __ ]
yeah you can you can get their deodorant
and body wash in amazing scents like
coconut and vanilla don't do the boys
citrus and herbal musk
lavender and rose and more oh that's
selling man
you know it's
it veers
i think between the two like there's a
road to be fair it's denzel playing al
sharpton
pretty much
um native deodorant uh ladies and
gentlemen if you were on a desert island
i was back to my plane analogy let's
continue i don't want to leave people
hanging with like what the [ __ ] dark
confession was that um i don't know i
never i never sometimes i die in the
dream and then i keep watching what
happens after i leave and [ __ ] it's kind
of dope this isn't one of those though
what i was gonna say is imagine you jump
out the plane you [ __ ] land on a
desert island with just your luggage and
in your luggage as a bar of native
deodorant you could eat it
maybe i think so listen
plant-based uh well
yeah
but maybe don't eat it
well i mean it's a stretch it's desert
island in this situation man they got to
survive all disclaimers are off yeah if
you gotta eat you gotta eat this is true
this is like lost if you're on lost and
[ __ ] if only jack had some naded
it's a whole different show if they're
all chowing down native when they landed
like we like to smell better maybe
uh on the inside uh so yeah stay fresh
stay clean i like that
uh with native by going to nativedeo.com
fatman or use promo code fatman at
checkout get 20 off your first order
that's
nativedeo.com fatman or use promo code
famine at checkout
for 20 off
your first order silky voice [ __ ]
slow that [ __ ] down yeah really he did
warm the quiet storm give it up for the
[ __ ] folks at native man
[Applause]
uh we thank the good folks at native for
sponsoring uh fat man beyond many many
times good lord man they've done it a
bunch means we have a stink yeah we have
a stinky audience i guess they're always
buying the native um all right where do
we go first into the news oh no we saw a
movie
that's right before we've seen lots of
[ __ ] since last we were here yeah well
like what well we both saw dune
yesterday yes which we could talk about
yes we can talk about in a non-spoilery
way because we are still a couple weeks
out
then again it's been a book for i was
gonna say five years i i think it's
tough to spoil dune man well i mean but
to me they're also all right spoilers
sting is not in this one
[Applause]
in fact [ __ ] fade isn't it at all
well we haven't gotten there yet is that
right so what did did david lynch cram
him into the other dude i mean the david
lynch's 1984 dune is the whole first
book
and
spoilers
maybe this is not the whole first book
because denny i think it's been well
covered up the evil dude has gone on
record saying he hopes he gets to make a
part two because this very much ends on
a what happens next tune in next time
same sand time same sand place this
movie is out overseas correct it's out
overseas it drops on the 22nd on hbo
maxin in theaters
um we saw it in a 40x uh theater thanks
to our good friend deacon man bretty can
let us come watch the show on 40x and
i'll tell you it heightened the
experience for me there's a lot of
flying in the movie and [ __ ] the
chairs were like this the whole time it
was kind of dope and then for the
battles it was you know chaotic very
windy movie very much so there's a lot
of rain scenes in the movie and so like
there's chairs on the button that says
water yes or no
and i chose yes and i was regretting it
because
i got [ __ ] soaked watching [ __ ]
dune i was trying to push it off in the
middle of it but it was too late
wrap it in your face if it rains on
screen and you're watching in 4dx which
i fully recommend not just because
it was a great experience for us but
it's [ __ ] f it's a fun way to watch
the movie
um
especially a movie which some of us have
seen before
a different iteration not that they're
the same [ __ ] movie but they are
based on the same source material so
there's you know there's
it's tough to say like we're gonna spoil
it
there's it's been plus there's a book
like he said so it's kind of weird like
being in that chair
i think enhanced the experience for me
not like the movie's not well made it's
beautifully [ __ ] made and stuff denny
villeneux is a genius that being said
like you know
the story doesn't really deviate from
the story
so they're going into it there's like
about five minutes into it i had this
feeling of like
oh [ __ ] i know this entire story
like and i knew that going in but now i
was like fully cognizant of it i'm like
what am i [ __ ] and even no matter how
you know well it's done like there was
also a tv mini series and [ __ ] so
i was like am i gonna and then the
[ __ ] chair started whipping me around
and blowing me and i was like this is
the best so i i had a a great [ __ ]
time like with that version of the
screening i you know i'm sure i would
have enjoyed it at home but it didn't it
enhanced the the screening and it's a
big movie so like i don't want to be
that dude he's like you need to go see
this in the theater but it helps because
it's huge yeah it is pretty massive uh
pretty gorgeous you know he's we've seen
him do versions of space before
blade runner arrival and this is him
doing the story he's always wanted to do
apparently he's a big [ __ ] dune fan
going back and you know he has respect
for lynch's version but he's like you
know i think there's a way to do it
that's just different and he's i don't
know if he's right because it's
beautiful
insanely well made but like again it's
you said it best why don't you why don't
you go first well it's like
and again i love the movie [ __ ]
unqualified rave absolutely love it but
it's a movie that we've seen before
based on a book that's been around for a
while right it's like you love a song
and then you've heard like three or four
different covers of that song and each
one of those covers adds something
different to it and there's a different
shade and whatever it's like all on the
watchtower oh i love jimmy's version of
it that pops ain't bad either and then
[ __ ] steven yvonne did one like
everybody had their their take on it and
so it's another cover of a song that i
love and it makes some interesting
choices like the david lynch cover had a
lot of spoken word in it
like there's there's a lot of voice over
in that one which was a conceit of the
book right right the book has a lot of
internal monologue which every other
filmmaker was like i don't know how you
[ __ ] do this this is a lot of people
just talking themselves david lynch was
like [ __ ] it they're going to talk to
themselves
and that's it
and you know it was like one of the most
memorable and enjoyable aspects of that
movie that never bugged me i always
thought that was kind of dope probably
because i'm a comic book person so i'm
like i'm used to the internal monologue
but i thought it was like well
represented
at the time particularly and
going into this you know i'm like well
like will they do that is there a need
to do that and
they did not do that and it would have
been cool if they did do they repurpose
some of those lines in dialogue and
subtitles or whatever and doing some
sign language but at least three or four
times he leaned over to me it's like
my son lives
he just starts like adding the parts
that were internal narrations
[Applause]
based on the old dune and [ __ ] lady lady
jessica walks in after the benny jesuit
uh mother
test paul with the box and in the in
david lynch's dune like it's very
dramatic where she comes in the room and
you hear her thoughts and she goes my
son lives
so when that moment happened in this
movie and there was dead silence i
leaned over to margo's like my son lives
and that i was laughing in a movie that
does not invite laughter
[Applause]
thank god we was a private screening
us it was a warner brothers security guy
who was really [ __ ] cool and had some
great inside stories and [ __ ] um and
also brett deacon was there so it's not
like we disturbed anybody but
you know
there were a few moments where you
missed that voiceover i'd say but it
didn't ruin the movie bunny stretched
the imagination it was a choice and you
know he made probably the smart
safe commercial choice of like let's not
do the crazy voice-over [ __ ]
but i kind of missed the crazy voiceover
[ __ ] like it worked for me i mean say
what one will about the david lynch
version um he went for everything he did
like as far as you could push it he
pushed it [ __ ] all the internal
dialogue yes let me show you this vagina
creature that's going to bend space in
time yes like everybody's high on drugs
yes
[ __ ] why is sting not wearing any
clothes yes like all of that is in there
like he just [ __ ] went for it and
then he made me want to watch that dune
again man i mean you should it's great
it is but daniel newton is not that guy
and so he's a little bit more reserved
he's more he's more kubrick than that so
it's very
i'm not going to say placid as a
negative but it's it's beautiful and
stately and everything is just wide and
gorgeous and heavy like he built a lot
of [ __ ] [ __ ] for this movie and it
shows and it's gorgeous but it doesn't
have that like we're just [ __ ] going
for it it's the restraint of a
storyteller trying to tame something as
opposed to just writing this [ __ ]
beast wild like david lynch did
um
yeah and that's not a negative i'm not
saying that an integrator is a
pejorative agreement a different take
yeah
the my i like
i thought the movie was beautiful i
enjoyed every minute of it
as previously reported elsewhere and we
mentioned it here it just kind of stops
you know in that lord of the ringsian
kind of like let's start walking away
and you know no nothing wrong with that
i guess but like the david lynch version
of dune that i was accustomed to at
least has some sense of closure
depending on which version you watch
it's you know [ __ ] haphazardly kind
of laid together to be like all this
[ __ ] happened too
but at least there's a sense of like oh
you know [ __ ] the good guys won i
think yeah whereas on on in this version
there's no
like there's a fight in the third act
that closes the movie but it's not like
a gigantic space battle it's a very
kind of personal one-on-one that's like
more sad than anything else you don't
feel
like victorious it's not like you're
like oh [ __ ] man you don't leave the
movie going like [ __ ] yeah paula tradies
you're like oh that poor son of a [ __ ]
man
that poor emo kid like
can't wait to see him be willy wonka
because he's so sad
[Laughter]
um i thought he was wonderful that was a
kid that like you know i love kyle
mclaughlin's performance and stuff so i
didn't really think uh going into this
like oh [ __ ] timothy chalamet who the
entire world seems to absolutely adore
um i thought he was wonderful i thought
he's a great paula tradies
he's slight
is paul trady supposed to be big um not
especially big or small but like he
takes off his
shirt and you're like oh you should eat
something
if you're gonna conquer space and time
maybe i have a cheeseburger for the road
the queen zac zarak is built like a 12
year old boy
that wasn't in the prophecies oh well
the quizadz twinker act
twinkarat
um beautifully cast uh beautifully made
crazy that the dialogue doesn't match
the lynch version now you read the books
yes which version it seems like the
lynch version just took a lot of
dialogue yes or no i think they just
kind of pulled wholesale of like we like
this pretty well written let's just do
that
whereas denny and his uh co-writer
didn't they seem to craft all new [ __ ]
yeah i mean the scenes were all the same
scenes like they they embroidered a bit
here and there and there are some lines
that do sort of work their way around to
be in what was in the book but there's
it's it is just it's a cover version
that has a lot more kind of
less guitar solo and more kind of
mournful
feelings about [ __ ] it's like a it's
like a slow build it's like in the air
tonight before you get to the drum break
sure that's what [ __ ] warner brothers
yeah what's up wants to put on a poster
they're like it's kind of like phil
collins in the air tonight
which we all really like this is an
interesting thought where's he going
with this
oh [ __ ] he stuck before it was good
i mean there is that kind of feeling of
like oh this is and i knew it was going
to end prematurely because they told us
on the internet for a long time but i
didn't know is that premature i was like
oh [ __ ] there's no closure whatsoever
yeah um they put part one right up in
the title it says dune part one or
something like that so very uh
that smells hopeful to me
it's it's a dare at this point what uh
what it cost because it's making money
overseas right it's been already
released overseas it's doing pretty well
overseas
they i haven't seen an exact budget
figure i think it was cheap for warner
brothers space operas so like 140
million dollars
130 140 something like that it's no
snyder cut
but it's also you know not [ __ ] the
departed either
oh good pull
thanks i don't know why
um he uh has an unblemished record that
director as far as i'm concerned one of
my favorite current filmmakers working
today and uh he did not drop the dune
ball whatsoever man like uh he's but he
should make another move well it's not
up to him to pick it back up again yeah
i mean
like
it just it would feel so [ __ ] weird
if that was it though like now we're
never going to do it again ever
because
yeah it's just like what wait [ __ ]
like imagine if you saw that
without having without any dune
experience whatsoever like at least i go
in knowing the lynch movie
so i can fill in blanks or like project
into the future you know the true source
material what do you think that
experience would have been like for
somebody who's like i never read the
book i never saw david lynch or anything
like that how many people in this room
have never seen an or read an iteration
of doing put your hands together
so like total [ __ ] dune virgins going
into that how do you think it'd play for
a dune virgin who's just like sci-fi
um i hope well i feel like you guys
should all come back
like on the 29th of october whenever we
do the post dune opens show mm-hmm like
what do you think like how did it work
because it was so hard for me
to know how to read that which is if i
knew nothing about this like i remember
going to see laura the rings with my
wife who had never read the books and
you get to the end of fellowship and she
literally would if there was a table in
that theater she would have flipped it
it's like what the [ __ ] is this
i gave you three hours and you even
[ __ ] get there
garbage
and like and you're like i've heard that
in the bedroom many times
this little
the wrap it up button wrap it up
[Applause]
to be fair wrap it up after three hours
is you know i mean you've been working
on it yeah really it's not for lack of
effort [ __ ] anything stops being fun
after three hours
except ted lasso
oh sweet ted lasso season finale was
wonderful anyway back to what you were
talking about um so i don't know i'm
curious i'm very curious to know if a
newbie audience coming through with
fresh eyes
gets what they're looking for i did
because i know the song and i like the
song um but so yeah after after it opens
we'll have to reconvene the council of
glorfindle and uh and have a
conversation
um this is what uh and this has nothing
to do with uh
the movie itself
which again uh i really really did enjoy
a lot um
that was the you know i [ __ ] watched
the david lynch version many many times
that's not an exaggeration
um i've not read the book but i felt
like i was fairly
familiar going in
maybe it's because there's not a lot of
no voice over in this maybe it's because
you know
it's a very subdued take compared to
lynch's
you know very almost indie film [ __ ]
take on the source material
um whereas he his was like indie film
sensibility and denise is like art
art film sensibility
this was the first time though that i
was sitting there going like
[ __ ] man like i love that [ __ ] they
said it on a
desert planet and when this [ __ ] uses
a voice on a person it makes them do
what they want and this boy
is gonna [ __ ] become the savior man
and [ __ ] stop evil in the
galaxy [ __ ] this is star wars and then
you know i realized wait [ __ ] star wars
is dune because they went first right
yeah dune doom was a book in the 60s
i mean has nobody like does george lucas
owe frank herbert like a check like
think about it a lot of the concepts we
love from star wars
come directly from [ __ ] dune yeah i
mean there's the the crate dragon
skeleton in like the fifth shot of star
wars that is indicating there are worms
on tatooine on a sandy planet
fancy that
and you know [ __ ] like the boy who
would be king the savior story the like
all of it like just
you know i mean changed just enough
you know it's obviously not like this is
the
dune is a is a is the kind of uh bible
version of the story and star wars is
the [ __ ] movie pop culture version
like [ __ ] pew pew like
it was almost like he was like what if
we made dune but left all the boring
parts out
you know and just and really boiled it
down to like
who the good guys are and the bad guys
are and make it real [ __ ] clear
because as you watch dune you're like
yeah the well as i've always known them
the harkonnens or as they call them now
they're harkenins which i guess is the
pronounce correct pronunciation you know
tomato tomato i guess um they're you
know ostensibly the bad
guys
but they're not
the bad guy somebody else is pulling
strings and you don't even meet that
[ __ ]
no the emperor who's literally called
the emperor
[Laughter]
oh my god
[Laughter]
i mean like all with all due respect to
my entire childhood hero but like it's
pretty [ __ ] shameless man i mean the
goodwin's borrowing the great one steel
i guess wow man wow i'm like
there's some sort of film out there that
compares this and
demands justice i mean like can we get
the [ __ ] snyder verse kids behind
this just to get george lucas to admit
like yeah i stole it from dune
but
but i gave all the money away so [ __ ]
yous
didn't he give all the money away
not all of it because he's not he's not
gonna be the [ __ ] dukes like living
in the side of the road like begging for
change
maybe that's why he gave the money away
the frank herbert estate was finally on
to him and [ __ ] he's like we gotta get
rid of this [ __ ] dune money quick
uh well you you've got a post clerk's
three project now is make a movie
analyzing the two films
i'm not smart enough
you wouldn't need to do that sort of
thing i'll finance it you do that okay
done
we'll do it as a youtube video it'll be
very inexpensive here we go
better eight minutes long
um yeah man like cribbed a lot
uh yeah a bit
a little bit
who do you think made more money
doing that story
frank herbert over all this time or
george lucas
gotta be lucas right it's gotta be lucas
i mean books sell don't get me wrong but
like not to the tune of like we have a
billion dollar grocery store oh banff
man has joined us later i think the
answer to that can be summed up by how
many dune figures did you have when you
were growing up
[Applause]
one and it was the baron harkonnen to
answer your question
because i [ __ ] support fat guys in
action figures
i would have bought a perkins if they'd
ever done it and [ __ ] well i had the
bespin fade ralpha and the hoth fade
around
the imperial fade thing i had all of the
ralph's all the ralphas um yeah good
point good point
i guess frank herbert's like [ __ ]
dolls did he live to see a version of
dune i don't know was he around for the
for the david lynch version i'm not sure
no he was already gone
ah poor lad
i bet you would have loved it at the
time the world hated it and [ __ ] i dug
it a lot but the world was like what the
[ __ ] but i bet you he would have been
like happy like oh my god look at my
concepts playing up on the silver screen
this movie's gonna make a billion
dollars uh it didn't grow yeah it was a
big notorious flop yeah
and you know i'm sure we've covered this
a million times but
to tie it back into lucas holy [ __ ]
lucas asked lynch
to direct return to the jedi and lynch
passed to do dune yep
how [ __ ] up would jedi have been
[Applause]
like good and [ __ ] up like proper
[ __ ] up
like is yoda dead i know his ear is in
the lawn
many he walks coming from under the door
laughing at you and [ __ ] like that very
mulholland drive
the emperor's got a log
sitting there with his log yeah my log
knows things
say it again
herbert died in 86 when the movie comes
out 84.
the movie came out in 84 he died in 86
we know what [ __ ] killed him
he's like i [ __ ] saw dune what the
[ __ ] like you've been putting it off for
a couple of years because like i'll get
to it when i get to it and the videotape
was sitting in his in his study music
how bad can it be today's the day i've
got a new glass of port let's try this
um wow
you learned something on this show
uh the movie is uh great you can go see
it in theaters as mark suggested uh or
if you got hbo max you literally watch
it at home i was glad to see it in 4dx
again i'm what the [ __ ]
i like went for it a fly that goes right
on your nose like what the [ __ ] are you
that's a ballsy fly
with a death wish yeah no kidding or one
that's just like [ __ ] you
wear a mask excellent point
um there it is folks that's our uh dune
review man danny villeneux does it again
uh a couple quick hit reviews i saw the
new bond movie
didn't try to die did you yes about as
long as dune was
um about two hours and 40 some odd
minutes of james bond did you see it in
40x i did not so uh my kidney stones are
still there
cause 40x will [ __ ] up a kidney stone so
funny brett was like i don't think the
vibrator is working today the vibration
in the chair and we're like all right
[ __ ]
the vibration was working so hard my
tits were hitting me in the face and
[ __ ] i was like oh it's working jesus is
fine
i came three times
um i really dug this bond um
i mean i know that there's you have to
watch all the other daniel craig bonds
to understand this did they marvel eyes
that [ __ ] um you don't need to watch
them all it helps if you had seen casino
royale his first bond and then spectre
his second to last bond simply because
there's telling a love story and those
two include this his uh o'jay d'amore
but not in skyfall no
no
but the action is [ __ ] great daniel
craig is leaving it all on the field um
the villain's plan doesn't make any
sense but you could count on one hand
the number of bond villain plans that
makes sense yeah it's less like it's oh
he's colorful it doesn't have to be
smart
i mean lachief was the smartest one and
his was about like poker and money
laundering like oh i get it well
moonraker dude was stealing a moon
maybe
like chair face chippendale he wanted to
write his name on the moon and he just
got to cha yeah
oh well remembered man
um so yes i if you're a bond fan at all
i would recommend it um
[Music]
bennett this is the last one right for
him the last one for him
i'm done really well they got to cast
the new guy who they haven't announced
yet but there's going to be a new person
it will probably be a man because
they're [ __ ]
um
how ironic how ironic
um so yeah it's going to be it's going
to be a beat um the what if season
finale we hadn't talked about did we not
talk about that at the home show
[ __ ] phenomenal are you sure i
thought i talked about it it was a
tuesday and it aired on a wednesday so
right yeah good points i watched that
[ __ ] at three in the morning man bawled
my eyes out it was [ __ ] fantastic
they stuck the landing on that show
um it was such wonderful writing such
like
imaginative
um and and you know
kind of bringing it all together i
i you know i'm supposed to be a writer i
didn't see that [ __ ] coming even though
there was a trailer that indicated
he was going to bring them all together
i was like no no
i can't believe they do that and [ __ ]
bam they did i was like oh my god they
have a [ __ ] team
never saw that coming it was so good was
a little confused because i was like did
i miss the gamora episode but i guess
they're gonna do that next season i read
um but man [ __ ] fantastic you um i
really dug it because and it seems my
pattern now with these marvelous shows
is i kind of like them at the top at the
top i lose a little faith in the middle
and then they bring me back at the end
because as long as you end well that's
what matters the most start good and end
well the middle can sag that's when
people go for popcorn take a [ __ ] stuff
like that
but the last thing they see when they
leave the theater has to be some [ __ ]
magic if you hope that they're gonna
tell people to come on back that's the
impression the lasting impression you
walk out on walk out with is the third
act yeah and so i like that it stopped
being an anthology and started being
another thing
um
watching the [ __ ] watcher stop
watching um was [ __ ] badass i know he
stopped cucking out and he got in on the
sex and [ __ ]
he's like i can [ __ ] too it was dope man
we saw him fighting the episode before
but it was cool where he's like you've
been chosen and [ __ ] brought the team
together
um very very cool that's cool um
we talked a little bit about ted lasso
season two finale but i [ __ ] i saw on
twitter somebody said
um watch the movies going forward to see
if they stick the watcher's eyes
in the sky and stuff like you know how
sometimes throughout the show you would
just see him in the clouds or whatever
the [ __ ] if they did that i would be
very okay with that see if they also
went back and retroactively added the
eyes for everything on disney plus
[Applause]
see um you could tell i'm the guy that
made clerks because i go for the
cheapest version possible
mark is a visionary who's like they can
really literally update every movie on
disney plus you're absolutely [ __ ]
right oh my god that's dope that'd be
dope
uh ted lasso wait a second who had this
uh book because kevin smith singer said
so i'm saying to both of yous
thank you
on to you yes um i know the internet
part of it was a little shitty about the
second season of ted lasso um i
personally loved it and i love weather
yeah me too with with nate everybody
caught up on ted lessou
um the dark nate returns
after our very own um yes what did you
think of that storyline i thought it was
great yeah i thought it was earned like
when you go back and watch the season
two you're like oh yeah [ __ ] all the
seeds are there and stuff yeah because
if you want to if you want to break an
audience's heart yeah you take the thing
that they love the most the thing that
seems the most innocent and and
unsullied and then you break it you know
and so nate was a puppy at the end of
the first season a puppy who seemed to
love ted lazzo more than anything and so
the then storytelling
inertia is going to he's going to go
dark we're going to push him to the edge
we're going to break this guy and break
your hearts as a result and i was
[ __ ] here for it yeah me as well
you know and the actor seemed to relish
it because he went [ __ ] hard into
that spitting at himself in the mirror
look at those kids i know we were so
young once oh
clerk's photo yeah him spitting in the
mirror was like dark and they did it in
an episode where i was like wait
like this is a hopeful show a very
positive show and i was confused i was
like are they indicating that that's a
thing positive people do
it never played like that for me that
seems kind of self-loathing and it turns
out it was yeah and you know ted lasso
as a show seems to be one about
redemption and so how better to to
dramatize that by giving them a darth
vader to redeem
oh you think that's where it eventually
goes i i god i hope so
because like him in a clock tower doing
some bad [ __ ] seems off-brand for that
show see i'm so catholic i just want to
see him punished
you know what i'm saying like he should
go to hell for what he did to ted lasse
that [ __ ] like
like dressing down that he gave him when
he [ __ ] like comes and he just tells
him like you're a [ __ ] joke and all
that [ __ ]
heartbreaking heartbreaking man any of
it earned i was sitting there the whole
time talking at the tv and yelling at my
wife
going like [ __ ] i was like [ __ ]
ted didn't deserve this and she's like
yeah i know but [ __ ] sometimes people
go that way what did you think about his
meltdown is there any of it that's
justified i i don't feel like any of his
justified except from the weird twisted
perspective of nate
which is this is the version of the
world he's chosen to see
and so it's it's a self-fulfilling
prophecy i think that i'm being held
back by this guy so everything that he
does i will see is a slight and as a
wound and as an attack and so by the
time we get to the end he feels
justified even though ted our audience
proxy and us are like what the [ __ ] are
you talking about but if you watch the
show again and the actor um nick
mohammed put up this great thing on
twitter
tracking the storyline of nate and how
he turns bad and every instance that he
feels unseen and sullied and
disrespected and overlooked and it all
[ __ ] tracks down to like one of his
big things in his big speech was i gave
you a picture of you and i and it's not
on your [ __ ] desk i see a picture of
you and and roy and a picture of you and
beer but me and you our picture isn't
here and the audience will remember that
that picture of him and nate is at home
with ted next to a picture of his son
yeah so it's even more dear to him but
nate never saw that and so nate is using
that as ammunition to feel a certain way
and given his perspective it checks out
even though he doesn't have the whole
picture to me it feels like he got
rupert you know [ __ ] spilling poison
in his ear so he's justifying and he's
[ __ ] like literally gaslighting the
[ __ ] guy who gave him a leg up and
stuff and and uh justifying why he's
gonna make the move that he's gonna make
and stuff the honestly the most
heartbreaking moment though is seeing
the shredded believe sign yeah
especially after watching like the whole
[ __ ] oh i'm gonna get choked up talking
about i love that [ __ ] show so much
i was hiking around [ __ ] the
reservoir today and uh up at lake
hollywood and if you do it twice it's
like six miles so i've been doing that
lately and i'm on if i'm very emotional
it's because i'm on hour
71 of a fast um so yeah right now i'm
feeling all the [ __ ] feels uh but in
any event as i was walking the reservoir
today i downloaded a few episodes just
to like listen to and play like a
podcast they [ __ ] absolutely work
it's dialogue porn and [ __ ] even
though i'm not watching it i still get
[ __ ] chills i get tears like it is so
wonderfully [ __ ] put together um but
even that scene like just walking around
listening to that scene i got so [ __ ]
emotional like it's heartbreaking like
that that
the betrayal is one thing like finding
out that nate kind of gave trent krim
the independent uh the story is
heartbreaking but like
the this was just
so much worse but at the same time as a
fan of the story i was so delighted by
the turn i was like oh it's going to
make for an excellent season three
because he knows [ __ ] all of ted's
strengths and weaknesses as he coaches
another team and stuff and oh love it
absolutely love it
speaking of emotional i finally finished
squid game
oh welcome to the rest of the [ __ ]
world man little [ __ ] light sweet
[ __ ] i know oh my god what the [ __ ] uh
you turned me onto it and i [ __ ] i
watched them all once i sat down i was
like this [ __ ] rocks what was your
final summation i i'm i'm blown away by
that show because it did not have to be
as emotional as it was
you know like it just could have been
the [ __ ] gains agree it could have
just been like
it could have been brutal and visceral
and that would have been enough and
clever and that would have been enough
but there are episodes that that use the
games to push moral quandaries for each
of these characters yes
that are based entirely on
presupposition like i think this game is
going to be this so i'm going to choose
this team that will get me this
but the game is designed to take
advantage of those presuppositions
to the point where all right you husband
and wife need to play marbles against
each other oh that was so [ __ ] up so
[ __ ] up and they didn't even [ __ ]
like deeply follow that storyline they
just gave you the setup and then the
[ __ ] payoff later on which was just
like oh my god
yeah i mean the whole the whole numbers
and the glass panel bridge thing
of like you have to choose what number
you wear and what that means the order
you're going to go but the advantage
might not be going first but going at
the last but you run out of time if you
like all of the different ways those
games are built to [ __ ] with you
psychologically and emotionally um i
just thought it was brilliant like
because it come becomes about character
and it's not just a gimmick anymore and
the fact that it it's as good as it is
and didn't have to be yeah
literally just could have been like
watch us kill people it's that
entertaining but they they put soul into
it yeah i thought it was great
um the last bit of tiny upfront news is
apparently there's a date that you
announced today
on the internet
that's right uh yeah we put up uh the
artwork for uh by uh nathan baird for uh
the part two
of masters universe revelation
that that image is not it
uh that was an old image from season one
do you not have the poster
yeah it's unnecessary they can find it
on the internet and [ __ ] oh is that an
andrew thing
the toys no worries no worries you were
so fast with a sharpie before you can do
anything you want you could [ __ ] up for
the rest of the night andrew that
sharpie move i was like what a ninja man
he just dropped out of nowhere tom
cruise on rope style and gave me a
[ __ ] sharpie it was impressive as
[ __ ]
um yes uh we put out an image today and
when i say we i mean netflix and
uh everyone involved uh that shows off
uh you know um
an image from uh the next five part two
of revelation and more importantly
announce the date when it's going to
drop on netflix as the kids used to say
that date is november 23rd it's a
tuesday i believe right before
thanksgiving
so that means you got all thanksgiving
weekend to
luxuriate in the second half the back
half of masters of the universe
revelation a thing that we
we wrote we did a thing yeah
[Applause]
um yeah so they announced and uh it's
coming i saw a trailer and the trailer
is [ __ ] fantastic
um so
who knows when they're going to release
that well i do i just can't say
um
but it knows what evil looks in the
hearts of men i know i do
me and the algorithm we're like this so
i know it's uh forthcoming and when
people see it they'll be like oh uh it's
really really well done um yeah can't
wait for people to see
see the rest of it today is he-man's
birthday is it yeah it was his 30th 39th
birthday today oh young buck yeah for
him
i've been very careful not to
say that on the internet because then i
thought a bunch of people be like why'd
you [ __ ] kill him [ __ ] you know
but yeah he's uh he's and if you look at
the key art there it is there's the key
art right there
um see the guy in the foreground looks
like a very
um uh different version of he-man um
they've uh it's kind of pre-spoiled it
by putting in the artwork and then they
also released this story today do you
have the toy
throw that image up andrew
there you go that's the toy uh which is
coming out november 23rd as well the
master of the universe tourism
for revelation they i mean they always
saw well but our revelation toy sold
incredibly well um the
this is a savage
he-man and orco 2-pack
and the idea of savage he-man is like
what happened and i'm i'm
like spoilers if you don't want to know
the [ __ ] but it's already out there on
the toy packaging and whatnot but the
concept was
what happens if adam calls down the
power without the sword as the conduit
um as something that kind of governs who
he becomes and with the you know one
point in the show he calls down the
power without the sword and becomes
the savage he-man and it's kind of based
on
the first incarnation the very first
drawing of he-man had a like [ __ ]
battle axe in his hand and he was much
more of the barbarian so we kind of
brought a flavor of that into it and and
you know when we uh we're making it
we're like nobody [ __ ] talk about it
but he's in the marketing right now so i
feel pretty good about talking about it
it's very phenomenal so i can't wait for
folks to watch the second half
interestingly i can't tell you
anything because though i
for many reasons i want to keep my
jobs
but there's part of the process when you
make a thing for netflix
where they have a call with you at like
the
maybe it's the 15-day mark or the 20-day
mark and the one-month mark or something
where they go through
the metrics and the [ __ ] the the
algorithm essentially and tell you
exactly how many people [ __ ] watch
how long they watch which episodes they
[ __ ] watch um give you a percentage
about how many people are [ __ ] likely
to come back based on
it was
[ __ ] mind-bending like like
mind-bending in turn again i can't share
it because it's so like proprietary and
whatnot but i had a very simple question
about
like
how does
in the movie world they make a movie for
like 10 million bucks and you know if it
makes [ __ ] 10 million bucks or more
at the box office you're like all right
we [ __ ] got our money back i was like
do you have that
at netflix and they were like yes
a version of that and
based on that they're very happy again i
don't want to say [ __ ] because i get in
trouble
but it was [ __ ] fascinating this the
the all the information
that they could give you like about the
show
nothing that i've ever done before
could i have that much data
uh that soon in the process it was
flabbergasting to say the least um so
yeah based on that i can't wait for the
second half to drop man it's gonna be
gonna be fun uh but enough about that um
ready for some news yeah let's do some
[ __ ] news mark bernard used to be a
news man and uh now he's not but he
still likes to
moonlight from time to time as bruce
willis used to say and uh he wants to
uh
do the old job of being a news person
without having to be a news person so he
collects the news for us and right now
mark bernard is going to bring you the
news give it up for mark bernard with
the news
[Applause]
uh
tell me of your homeworld usual no tell
me of your love for adam warlock
um do you have any i mean it's not love
but but respect for the character uh
you're talking about a creation of uh
stan lee and jack kirby that's how far
adam warlock goes back he's got a weird
origin story that like
i think jim starlin and uh roy thomas
probably
improved upon later on but in the first
iteration
he's made by the if i remember correctly
he's made by the enclave they try to
come up with a perfect [ __ ] hero to
fight off these people that are
attacking the enclave and stuff
um they create a guy who calls himself
him they just call him him he's not even
called warlock or adam warlock
for the whole first story
uh then it gets picked up
later on the character at the end of the
story they he's in that pod and they
launch him back into space or something
like that
years later he got picked up by if i
remember god this is going deep
the high evolutionary
nice um is the one that like gives him a
purpose including
what they then called the soul gem
which would later on we would all come
to know as the soul stone
um adam warlock is a huge [ __ ] part
of in the infinity gauntlet story that
they based infinity war and endgame on
um so it was weird that they did it and
did it so well
without one of the main characters uh in
infinity gauntlet so um the high
evolutionary puts a gem in his head and
gives him a purpose uh the soul gem
literally collects souls of evil uh he
sends him to if i remember correctly
counter earth which is kind of like
marvel's version of earth 2. um it's on
the other side of the sun it was a piece
of earth that broke off in the formation
of the earth and it became uh
the the alternate earth and marvel and
stuff
and so
a lot of adventures with him happen on
that planet hulk goes there at one point
they're fighting the new men which are
like man beast i think was their leader
it's very
deep cuts i i know him best from
infinity gauntlet
um where he was kind of the herald of
the thing he was the one who came to
warn everybody like thanos is coming and
[ __ ]
um but
that all being said uh has a beautiful
[ __ ] costume and is a marvel fan
favorite uh forever i got respect for
the character but i was never like adam
[ __ ] warlock he's got a great name
that's about it i believe high
evolutionary gives him the name warlock
then when he comes to earth or other
earth whatever [ __ ] a bunch of kids he's
hanging out with they're like hey man
warlock's the last name you need a first
name and they call him adam and [ __ ] so
hence he becomes adam warlock for a dude
who's not that big a fan
you know the entire marvel handbook
entry it's true
[Music]
my god the [ __ ] i can't remember my
wife's birthday but
like i literally i just pulled a bunch
of [ __ ] from [ __ ] like 25 or more
years ago
and they say i'm a stoner
[Applause]
you're a pot of cheever my friend yeah
that's right um so he's going to be in
guardians 3.
yeah that's been the big news well i
mean we saw by the end of guardians 2
that adam warlock was coming she even
says i shall call him
atom
um and that cocoon thing is very
recognizable from the comics and stuff
although theirs was like a little more
metal
um who did they cast as adam warlock the
internet wanted
uh the boy from uh the high school
musical zac efron
uh they did not get zac efron oh they
got willed the internet didn't get what
it wanted oh [ __ ]
they're not going to be happy about that
no
uh they got will poulter who was in
detroit and the revenant and played like
every other like shitty boyfriend of the
girl that the hero of the movie would
eventually fall in love with
um that used to be like chris pratt's
job for a while meet meet the millers
yeah
he was a kid he was a kid and meet the
millers that's what i recognized the
most from yeah but he won out over uh
apparently let's see
reggae jean
page
was from bridgeton was being read as was
one of the kids from 1917 george mckay
were both on the short list um i mean
how to do this without sound and judgey
adam warlock is meant to be like the
perfect
specimen
so like you would imagine that reg guy
was probably
look at me yeah [ __ ] i mean that guy
[ __ ] i saw him i didn't watch
bridgeton but i saw him host snl and
i was like i would [ __ ] him
[Music]
they're right he's [ __ ] gorgeous so
he would have been a great choice man uh
will his name will poulter yeah yeah uh
has striking [ __ ] looks which i think
will look wicked in a costume and stuff
like that and make up whatever they do
but uh yeah strong choice man james gunn
co-signed it said this is true yeah it
was like i'd like to go on the internet
and dispel rumors when i see them but
turns out this is not a rumor this is
the real deal [ __ ] night man i can't
wait i'm just happy there's a guardians
3.
there's a christmas special first though
right is that coming soon or is that
next year bam oh batman's in he's got
some info tell us bam man so apparently
uh will poulter was cast to be in the
amazon
100 billion dollar lord of the rings tv
show and left
to do adam warlock
in march really
well he's no [ __ ] dummy
like that's you know marvel is just only
going to get bigger and bigger and
bigger and amazon
i mean
[Laughter]
i mean they're selling comic books now
so that's true that's true
it's an odd choice kind of a lot of
space it's more of a lateral move you
know what i'm saying like from leaving
one behemoth to another one giant to
another
um who's it gonna play in that lord of
the rings thing they didn't reveal but
the
the the
thought was it was elrong so the guy the
elf who was played
twin brother
elron's twin brother so uh leroy
agent smith from the matrix
yeah hugo weavings
who was in the peter jackson movies his
twin brother nice that's a character
from the books
what's the what's hugo weaving's name in
the in the is that elrond elderon
and then this guy's name is leroy leroy
no i didn't i don't know
leroy is it
what's his name uh i'm not sure i think
it's an original account somebody called
it out
what was it
nobody knows
nobody knows the guy's name was he ever
in the books are they making this [ __ ]
he's in
simarillion
no the deep appendixes or the appendices
he wasn't in like the story of the books
oh get the [ __ ] out of here yeah he's
like i was almost in the books but you
know they put me in the appendix and
[ __ ] but he would have been a big
character in
what is it
l rose
l ron danelle rose
i'd watch a [ __ ] ring show if they
were like the main character's name is
leroy
i'm like all right another middle-earth
nonsense some practical [ __ ] names i
could deal with this
his brother's name is lamont
and they run a junkyard right outside of
murkwood
you big gummy
i want to see it that's the big one
[Laughter]
um all right so that's good news for uh
will poulter he gets to beat warlock and
good news for us uh fans we get to see
warlock in a movie [ __ ] yeah and for
anybody that's like i don't get it like
you know think about it you didn't get
[ __ ]
groot until they put it in a movie and
they're like oh i get it hardcore it's a
talking [ __ ] tree that's amazing
same thing with adam warlock in the
hands of james gunn he's already an
interesting character on the comic book
page obviously they can't do the origin
and the stories that they've already
done in the comics that i was talking
about uh one because their origin is
already on a different path he's getting
created by the what are they called all
those gold people oh i can't remember
the leroys
um so it's already off you know from
what the original story was and uh they
can't do infinity gauntlet because
they've already done it and stuff so you
know i i trust james gunn is gonna use
them in
interesting ways it'll be very
reminiscent of his comic book tales of
old while not being the stories that i
seem to be so achingly unfamiliar with
yes
uh the sovereign is who they were the
sovereign did you just remember that no
i just read it
it's not a piece of paper yeah man
i'm not dude i'm not off book
it went fair enough all right so good
for will poulter but [ __ ] moving on
good for us um amc has greenlit a
another walking dead spin-off
this time it's called tales of the
walking dead it's anthology show oh yeah
which i think is super smart
yeah like at the end of the day you just
[ __ ] you don't you know never mind
the
soap opera of it just here's a story
about [ __ ] trying to live in
the zombie apocalypse essentially what
we used to do
with zombies tell one story and then
maybe do a sequel and [ __ ] before robert
kirkman had the brilliant idea of like
what if we just kept telling the story
and it just went on and on what if we
put zombies on tv every [ __ ] week
like one of the most brilliant
low-hanging fruit ideas of all time man
god bless him what if it's a soap opera
what if it's the young and the headless
and we're just going
oh my god
stealth that was lovely
um all right so they got an anthology
show that's cool the the interesting
part is that they can tell stories about
throughout the time of the show yeah on
the entire timeline so you can have new
characters you could have old characters
that have since left the show
return like if you needed
a rick story from like season two here's
the rickster you never saw if you want
glenn back
like we can get glenn back um i think it
opens them up to be able to do lots of
interesting things um from both giving
fans what they want and maybe even more
importantly what they need
which is the the stories of characters
that
you love but didn't know
so you can go back uh and tell a
herschel story if you wanted to
or yeah is he still around scott
so you couldn't uh well you could tell a
young herschel
young herschel the doctor
um
you could tell a [ __ ] wasn't a shane
store you can't protect a rick
[Music]
remember like that guy was the main
character like one of the main
characters and then [ __ ] they were
like
and he's gone as well yeah [ __ ] i mean
in the book i think he's gone in like
episode issue two or three i think so he
got to last longer because i think
everybody loved [ __ ] shane
give me that bernthal and shane loved
[ __ ] the other guy's wife
to tell us all this time i always
thought that was it did they do that in
the comic as well yeah i thought that
was such a great [ __ ] like twist in
that story like in the midst of a zombie
apocalypse this guy's like
did my wife sleep with my best friend
what the [ __ ] like you got bigger things
to worry about but still it was there in
the air and [ __ ]
a quiet moment like did shane [ __ ] my
wife
i i've stopped watching but
his wife stayed dead right
they never brought her back they never
brought her back i always thought like
because they never showed her death that
they were gonna pull like a fast one one
day and be like she's been alive this
whole time and [ __ ] the kid shot away
from her or something like that and she
never became a zombie but they never did
or she did become a zombie and we will
find that body wandering the wasteland
in season 11 then like that kid has to
kill his mom again
you're such a better writer than man
like yeah you could do that that'd be
dope
it'd be sad as [ __ ] but
cool too cool very metal and it would
get people to like talk about the show
like holy [ __ ] remember his mom he had
to [ __ ] kill her twice
but wait is he still around no no the
the daughter would be around because the
boy's dead too right that's when i
stopped watching
yeah you killed carl
um
[Music]
what season are they on eleven wow
yeah
good we should be so lucky i know
[ __ ] the 11 seasons of the show god
bless her our billionaire friend robert
kirkman
um speaking of spin-offs
you know who's getting her spin-off
it was agatha all along oh i saw that
yeah um good for her man so she's
getting like a loki-like series when
last we saw her she was trapped in that
little town and [ __ ] they got all the
sets indeed
um well maybe i don't know but yeah no
she's coming back catherine hahn emmy
nominated for playing agatha harkness is
returning jack schaefer who
was the head writer on the first season
of one of vision is coming back to do
this show as well
um and maybe this also is a bit of a
stealth sequel not just a spin-off to
one division because you'd have to
imagine that at some point wanda will
check up on she's gotta come back right
yeah
um i'm in i've watched her play that
character over and over again
milk that like they milk loki i'm all
for that hey marvel milk it
they're like don't worry we will
milk it yeah we got this yeah um
as we talked to our friend scott snyder
yeah no relation to the other snyder um
superman is equipping did you do you
think he should have called this comic
book snyder verse
i think he should have done a snyder cut
just [ __ ] lean into that skit
snyder cut press
snyder verse is right there but like
it's true it already exists
but snyder cut
well do they call it the snyder cut the
justices
but what do they call the movie it's
zack snyder's justice league that's it
yeah so he could get away with
snyder.com
he's like i named it after my kids [ __ ]
you guys and your dopey ass joke
it would always be trending whenever a
new book comes out
that's true that's what i'm just saying
that's true that's marketing right there
uh huh
should we keep going do what i don't
know it feels like you just slipped into
neutral for a second no it's like
there's marketing right there and in my
mind i heard you go yeah
is that what you said uh yeah
and then the show just stopped
i figured we were done but and you would
move on to another story but you're like
passing the ball back to me and i'm like
what me no it's your turn my turn
uh we talked to scott snyder um a little
bit and he mentioned the the the
jonathan kent the new superman that's
right he was coming out as bisexual big
news this week man
huge [ __ ] news
um very cool news uh i thought the best
take i saw on it was from my friend uh
brian lynch who wrote uh you know like
um the minions movies and stuff like
that hops stuff like that um worked was
it illumination for like a long time
um
he he tweeted he was just like
the people who will be hurt
by a superman
character being gay
is exactly zero the amount of people who
could be helped
by a superman character being gay is
countless i thought that was the
absolute best [ __ ] take on it man
he is a
[Applause]
a wonderful writer so it stands to
reason he would come up with something
perfect to say but
i can
naturally of course the internet a
portion of the internet was mad i take
it
you know the internet is going to do
what the internet is going to do
and and all too often it is the worst
indulgences of
the less
illuminated um
i would imagine there was a lot of
pushback
um not internally apparently internally
they were all about it like no from the
[ __ ] from the fans but like
well i mean i don't even know if it's a
fans it's a bunch of people who just
like what now superman's gay oh [ __ ]
this world and [ __ ] and not digging
deeper into the story at all to see that
it's not their superman it's jonathan
kent the son of
lois and clark who is the new superman
so even if you're like i like my
superman [ __ ] straight you can still
have straight superman this allows
somebody else to have a [ __ ] superman
as scott snyder said like you know
[ __ ] everybody would like to see
themselves perhaps with this character
so
lovely
and and and again perfect way to do it
without really disrupting anybody else
without being like everything you know
about clark kent is [ __ ] wrong
re-examine his relationship with bruce
wayne you know what i'm talking about
martha my ass but uh
that's what name did he named it
but you know it's it's i don't know it's
smart to just [ __ ] be like look we
got a couple supermans around here
so here like let's [ __ ] investigate
this a story we've never done
like you know in a world with no
internet
like you do that story and it probably
doesn't cause an uproar because people
reading comics are like yeah all right
[ __ ] in this iteration this character
is this now like they're used to dealing
with different [ __ ] iterations of the
character so you know naturally it's a
seems like a culture war [ __ ]
conversation talking point for a bunch
of people to get riled about and a bunch
of people to be happy about um i say we
lean toward the latter man seems like
it's good news right yeah it's an
original [ __ ] story at the very
[ __ ] lease never mind who it can help
and stuff if you're one of those people
that's like i don't give a [ __ ] who it
can help fine you're getting a brand new
story you've never [ __ ] heard before
read before scene before about a
character that you know a lot of stuff
about maybe not the exact same character
they grew up with but superman
nonetheless so
you know [ __ ] man appreciate don't
[ __ ] sit there and rail against it
like
yeah i mean who knows what comes out of
it and [ __ ] good stuff and you could
probably do it in the lowest in the
lowest clark show what is it called
[ __ ] the adventures of superman or
something yeah superman superman
is that really the name of that show
i would have went for another draft but
i mean i guess it seems to be working
and stuff good for them but they might
reflect on the show right because that
kid is a character on that show
yeah i mean listen if it's
i there's a bunch of different ways you
can go with it i think that there's also
the version of it like how superman is
like clark kent he's functionally
immortal right like what kills that dude
what do we know anything something not
sure kryptonite but like
if this dude's gonna be a thousand years
old
he's probably gonna [ __ ] dude at some
point just out of boredom
like that's your angle my
my angle is you're like if i lived to be
a thousand i would i'm gonna do
everything
let me tell you i don't have to wait
that [ __ ] long
but if i [ __ ] live to be a hunter i'm
gonna be like put a few in here man why
not i'm beating the curve [ __ ] go
ahead
like i'm just saying it would personally
wouldn't bother me if it was clark i
know clark just discovered a thing about
himself because people do that [ __ ] all
the time but you would understand how a
bunch of people would be like now
god damn it no
and then i would remind him he's a
fictional character made up by people so
[ __ ] true
people get people get very very tight
about the characters that they love but
they also again
they also get tight about [ __ ] they
haven't cared about in 30 [ __ ] years
and then read on the internet that
[ __ ] like something's been changed
and something they haven't given a [ __ ]
about maybe ever if not since childhood
yeah and then get [ __ ] furious about
it like you're gonna tell me that
heimdall a norse god is being played by
a black dude who's heimdall i don't know
he's norse though yeah he's a viking man
come on
so yes there's no limit to the amount of
shitty that people will get over stuff
they didn't care about before
but
that's also not a reason not to do
things so like i applaud 100
dc and tom taylor for just doing it also
like i mean i i honestly can't remember
the last time i've read
superman this makes me go like oh i'll
read that i want to see it i want to see
what they do that's an interesting story
again
interesting new take
on very familiar material and i remember
like talking to mike carlin [ __ ]
years ago when he was running the
superman division at dc
and he was like you gotta understand
comics are just all [ __ ]
act two
it's all middle story he's like there's
one origin yeah we can [ __ ] show it
again and again but that happened and we
never want to get to [ __ ] act three
because that's the end of all that [ __ ]
so that's how you finish so comics are
essentially [ __ ] act two over and
over and over again so he's like how do
you keep that interesting so sometimes
they're like guess what superman's
[ __ ] dead and then sometimes they're
like guess what superman's [ __ ] gay
and that's a way to keep it [ __ ] like
fresh like i'm as a reader i'm all for
it never mind how good it'll be for
other people and stuff like that to see
themselves represented which is [ __ ]
wonderful but like it's just an
interesting take on the [ __ ] material
and i'm sure it's gonna be handled
maturely i'm sure you know
it'll be smart yeah scott snyder was
right like tom taylor is a hell of a
[ __ ] writer yeah and i believe that
he's gonna he's gonna handle it with
care and with feeding and with not
feeding it after midnight and don't put
in the direct sunlight but you might
have to get it wet
be better
um the uh still that they put out the
still the frame i guess of the book
has that happened yet or that's
forthcoming i believe it's forthcoming
i believe the announcement was peg two
national coming out day oh is that what
it was yeah [ __ ] nice smart good for
them
um right on yeah and our last news story
is that in the sliding doors universe
of the dc uh
film
dimension
we almost had a catwoman played by
madonna
well that would have worked you think so
yeah sure absolutely oh my god that
really could have worked what happened
um
i will read you the story oh okay in my
uh should you want denzel to read this
yes
do it in the voice
ah now i got performance anxiety
elba that went poorly alice
um
no during a tonight show appearance with
jimmy fallon she fielded a bunch of
questions about her career did more than
that i saw a picture or two where she
crawled on the desk and showed off her
butt and stuff
good for her how old is she
she ain't 52. she's 28 years old no it's
been all over the press this week it's
like she's six minimum 63 or something
so
63. if i could [ __ ] i
at 25 i wouldn't have shown my ass you
know what i'm saying if you could pull
it off at 63 holy [ __ ] you're doing
something right yeah um but she said
that you know shooting out a bunch of
rumors among one of them was that she
turned down the role of catwoman and
batman returns as well as the lead in
showgirls and she confirmed them both
she would have played nomi and show
girls yes
even though she was a show woman by that
point
the show woman yeah but also just grown
up like she was there's no girl there's
no girl there like nomi what's her who
played uh what's her name um uh
elizabeth berkeley elizabeth berkley um
at least you know kind of looked
age-appropriate like girl in her 20s
breaking into vegas and stuff madonna at
that point when they made showgirls was
easily
well into her career and and probably
well into her 30s
i think they made the right choice wait
did she pass on them or they pass on her
she passed on them both
they offered her catwoman and she passed
on i think she made the right choice for
show girls but i think she totally could
have pulled off [ __ ] catwoman
um i mean you know we all love the
michelle pfeiffer performance so it
worked out but i could totally see that
and i'm also sad that that didn't happen
because we kind of got it she played in
[ __ ] dick tracy yeah but that was not
catwoman no but you know we got her
playing the femme fatale to the [ __ ]
comic book hero or the comic strip hero
and stuff oh so she did she talk about
that on jimmy fallon where she's like i
tried to rectify it by being in dick
[ __ ] tracy
i don't know what i was thinking man
but there was given that there might
have even been a world in which we got
an entirely madonna soundtrack for
batman returns ooh like the prince
soundtrack for batman that'd have been
dope that would have been good i'm
telling you she's like uh
she's she's been good and stuff and some
people give her a hard time because
she's not an actress but she i think she
grew into a really wonderful actress she
could have totally pulled that off
i would have watched a catwoman movie
with her
um oh well
celebi yeah and that's the news she
passed on them
did she say why
no
no
it was after dick tracy
yeah dick tracy was before batman
returns
is that dick tracy how do you know that
is it did the internet tell you are you
just saying that
based on recollection
i'm not saying you're wrong but i
remember batman came out in 89
maybe you're right maybe
91. dick tracy was 1990. 90. holy [ __ ]
boy they were right on the bandwagon
they're like that batman thing just
happened like [ __ ] it we need our own
you know who's the closest thing to
batman
dick [ __ ] tracy
he's a detective too
um wow wow well [ __ ] me in the mouth i
don't know what i'm talking about i'm
sitting there analyzing madonna from a
distance going she did dick tracy to
make up for the sin of passing on
catwoman and that's not true at all
so wait she did dick tracy first
then they came to her with catwoman a
sequel to a massive [ __ ] hit and she
still said no
it was like i got burned on that dick
tracy [ __ ] why am i gonna make another
comic book movie because it's [ __ ]
brand it's batman it's like the whole
reason they made dick tracy is because
batman had done well i don't know why am
i yelling at you it's not you're not
sure i didn't
i mean it would be madonna so i could
say this to a time i was 14 years old
but i said listen madonna you maybe
shouldn't do that
[Applause]
is your voice that high give me ten
percent
it's very tito get me a tissue that was
very high
um is that all the news yeah that's it
it's all the news that's fit to print
folks give it up to mark he brought you
the news
the news
[Applause]
um okay
uh
no other middle ad
no so we could just dive into uh we can
just
oh you know before we dive in let me
show you this thing that was here
um it is a thing that you know they
always send me
and you
premiums of stuff like
presuming like you know you'll tweet
about it or
instagram it uh you know we have a show
and this is pertinent to our interests
so i thought i'd bring it out and show
you they just sent it to me this
is i believe
uh from the good folks
at
fossil
uh if i'm correct let me see
yes
a fossil in partnership with warner
brothers consumer products ladies and
gentlemen
put it right there can you hold on to
that or fix that uh warner brothers
consumer products ndc is thrilled to
announce their batman by fossil
capsule collection featuring limited
edition watch box sets
leather goods and that won't stand up
and more in collectible designs that
even an arch villain would love good
copy nice good copy
um that's a manscape level yeah i like
that i'm [ __ ] proud of them the
collection is inspired by iconic
graphics colors and comics of the past
made for those who proudly call batman
their favorite superhero we want to see
how you wear batman by fossil if you
post your product please tag at fossil
oh
oh i guess i'm an influencer oh look at
you they want me to influence people um
yes but i am going to uh well this is
the influence right here uh they sent
this amazing [ __ ]
batman
backpack which i guess is
maybe leather
um it's got this cool [ __ ] batman
hanging off it and stuff like that but
inside
uh since you know it's fossil
there's watches
and the watches are amazing uh
give me your
what
hold your mic to my mouth
all right so you got yourself a [ __ ]
you know what jc you're standing right
there
put it right in the face of the camera
like display it like you're vanna white
like put bring it up there and show it
off you're too far away get right up
close do the thing and take the bag too
man i'm sure these [ __ ] are just like
who can see it that far away focus is
set here though so if you get close it
gets blurry yeah i mean i can change the
focus but don't [ __ ] do that
i mean
could you just walk seductively back and
forth yeah holding it yeah show it off
to the room we'll try it we'll try it
here we go let's see
you guys like narrate what's going on or
something so it's not no we're gonna
make it awkward as [ __ ]
you do it in silence
uh these are the fossil watches yeah
that's blurry as [ __ ] take it off that
looks terrifying do it slowly but look
at that [ __ ] man it's a
watch and it's got like four different
uh
wristbands watch wristbands you could
put on it and stuff uh gorgeous looking
thing uh i would uh offer it to oh yeah
a little light changes this [ __ ]
story well done filmmaker macgyver look
at that [ __ ]
um uh this is i would offer it as a
prize tonight but i promised this to uh
hollywood babylon's ralph garman who is
a massive batman fan so this is going to
good ol ralph but if you're into batman
and you're into watches you're into bags
and [ __ ]
fossil
has you covered man uh there you go
thank you jason you don't want to put it
back together the way it was all right
well he's got to get the [ __ ] in focus
now he's got to run a show oh there's a
nice pin in there as well
and uh somebody [ __ ] looked it up and
when i say somebody i mean my wife
because she was like ooh can i give this
away as a christmas present
and i was like to who and she's like you
like batman
i'ma give you this [ __ ] you just got
i was like i know where it came from
she's like i know but we don't need to
buy each other gifts anymore we've been
married for like two decades i was like
you get me a [ __ ] gift
um
cbs and you buy me some [ __ ]
chocolates yeah something give me a
veggie girl gift certificate [ __ ] but
she looked it up and the watch was like
a couple hundred bucks so it's pretty
sweet pretty sweet [ __ ] thing uh
ralph will enjoy it uh in any event
now on to the q a portion of our show
ladies what's happening with these guys
back here yeah bring that bring them on
somebody uh this is your
your kid's book is right here i'm gonna
put it over here
and then we're gonna bring up
another version of the [ __ ] book
anyway
uh because that
is uh one of our prizes tonight ladies
and gentlemen
that's right the [ __ ] kevin smith's
secret stash book an amazon best seller
in the very
very slim department of director books
[Applause]
um has uh it's it's [ __ ] gorgeous man
i was told to warn uh the folks out
there in the world that i don't know if
you've been following the news but
there's a lot of
um
shipping issues and and and uh supply
line issues and so i've been uh told to
warn people that if this is something
you want to get for christmas order the
[ __ ] now uh because they've got a bunch
printed but i know a bunch are sitting
on a boat waiting to come to the states
and stuff like that so
tonight uh we're gonna offer the book up
to uh
normally we let people just come up and
pick man but it's like you know if you
came up first you'd [ __ ] pick the
book it'd be wild if somebody didn't
they're like [ __ ] your life's work
i'll take the pop and [ __ ] walk to
the pop instead traveling light today do
we uh do we
[ __ ] should we do an
applause meter for the best question
i mean i don't want to pit people
against each other and [ __ ] like that's
nobody comes to this show to walk away
feeling like i'm less than somebody else
yeah
yeah who killed for this [ __ ] book
you could buy it on amazon for like 50
bucks or you could kill a man tonight
and own
and to be fair or a woman we're equal
opportunity here at fat man beyond
kill someone walk away with a book uh
how do we pick
i was gonna leave it in the hands of the
audience but you want some other metric
for success
always
always the one that [ __ ] works out
best for me
um
it's uh
your life
story so it should be like
maybe the person who asks the question
who's closest to age 37
yeah that's a lot of leather on that
shoe man
um i see what you were smart can't read
a [ __ ] book i see what you were doing
because that takes it out of
meritocracy and puts it in the hands of
age alone
smart
smart nobody's a bad guy then that's
true
except your parents
yeah it's true man for not [ __ ]
sooner
just waiting
um well
i don't know let's just get into it
we'll figure it out
i'm sure it'll occur to me well here's
the thing uh that's gonna be uh one of
the prizes tonight a book so heavy it'd
kill you if it [ __ ] fell on you like
that thank god nobody's head was there
um it also comes with a pair of 4dx
tickets kids 40x
the [ __ ] movie that makes you feel
like you're alive uh we watch dune in
40x and you will get [ __ ] wet ladies
and gentlemen
uh and then you're also gonna get a
print
from the dark nate himself
one of these gorgeous fat man beyond
prince which featured me and mark
um in the role of [ __ ] uh
twin 007s
oh we got a big ass dice
we could roll each question
person could roll the dice and whoever
gets the highest
that's it
but how do you do that you got then they
gotta wait until the end yeah they
collect at the end yeah that'd be fine
is that all right
all right fair enough there we go so
everybody rolls the die as well we
should keep this going that's fun
um everyone rolls the die and the
highest or what how what's the highest
number on the die uh 20.
so if you roll the not 20 up top then
you just walk away with a book and
everybody could just not roll
oh my god listen to how fast that came
out of your mouth
well i mean i'm uh you sounded like a
[ __ ] pit boss right there man
i got a plus two for gaming at bars yeah
i'm very very good a natural bonus uh
let's do that then uh was is it a nat 20
or do we pick like a nat 14 just to be
[ __ ] up well then we could be rolling
on that i feel like the highest roll
wins it's simple it's clean bam oh i'll
get you now i get you so even if you
roll
if you roll well what if everyone rolls
a natural 20. well then they fight
then a squid game then it's squid game
then the d exactly then that die is
[ __ ] loaded um all right everyone
will [ __ ] uh roll the die god this is
fun it's like a game show now um the
other prize is the same thing you get a
poster you get the 40x tickets and you
get a movie's pop they did a pop of
movies uh ironically enough 137
and uh it's signed so
these are the prize packages kids and uh
we'll be rolling die to see who gets
what but in the meantime
jc
what uh what are we gonna do all right
ask us please your question what's your
name sir i'm cohan from
actually i'm from michigan so i've been
here for about a month and came to the
show a couple weeks ago so it's been
great to see you guys oh awesome what an
amazingly long answer to a very simple
question
what was the first part what is your
name cohan cohan everyone give it up for
cohan man
how are you sir uh how was your time
here ben and excellent shirt by the way
this is a really crazy city i spent a
lot of time in detroit in chicago so
this is yeah i've been telling friends
back home la is it's crazy yeah it's got
good crazy sometimes right agreed agreed
um it has a different vibe than the
midwest to be sure
so i'm a professor of writing and
journalism fact i'm a recovering
journalist oh well welcome aboard
and i gotta say as a journalist back
when this was uh fat man on batman when
you're doing interviews yeah yeah great
interviews as a journalist i got to tell
you kevin really good questions you
really go deep with people it's just
really fantastic thank you
also as a professor this podcast has
been really helpful for some of my
students sometimes because i teach essay
writing some students are like hey i
don't know what to write about and i'll
say well what do you like as far as like
pop culture stuff movies tv shows so on
and so forth and they're like like what
does it have to do with essays i'm like
you can you can relate what happens in
pop culture to the real world and you
guys do a great job of that and i'm to
tell you there are people who have
gotten college degrees
in part because they're able to pass my
class because they were able to make
those kind of connections because i
introduced them to this podcast so how
can hey man we are professors now yeah
the master class of smog cove
that's beautiful thank you for that
that's very [ __ ] cool so for my
question okay imagine you're either
percy or jay jonah
and you have like an investigative team
what mystery of the dc or marvel
universe would you have your
investigative team go solve first
i mean with dc you're tempted to be like
batman's parents
but we all know
that joe chill did it
although in some iterations of the story
it wasn't joe chill or it was somebody
behind joe chill i guess they've done
that already i mean scott snyder kind of
did it with court of owls right
like there was a story it wasn't as
simple as like the waynes got shot in an
alley it was all connected to something
larger
which is also what they did in
tim burton's batman by linking the joker
into it
which you know was i remember there was
no internet at that point but fans of
the comic were i wouldn't say outraged
like they seemed to be over the
jonathan kemp thing online um but there
was like consternation over the fact
that like what
like the joker killed his parents no
that doesn't make [ __ ] sense uh for
people who've loved those books forever
and ever but for anyone who just you
know like my familiarity with batman was
they did a tv show once years ago and
[ __ ] like that you go into that story
like oh my god this works perfectly of
course the joker [ __ ] killed his
parents and they made each other he even
says it in the [ __ ] dialogue and
stuff
so yeah they they have done that story a
bunch hmm
hmm
you got an answer i do oh go
i'm just [ __ ] vamping
[Music]
in the marvel universe
i think i mean the mcu has has out and
sort of declared a change in national
policy
but for
some 10 000 years
wakanda has been a secret
and there have been map makers and
explorers and journalists and all kinds
of people throughout the years who have
you know explored into africa
and the undiscovered country the hole in
the map that nobody seems to know what's
in
feels like it's a story like what's
there and why can't we find out what's
there every map we have tells me that
there's a there's there's a big patch
where we don't seem to know anything
planes fly over but they don't see
anything like what the [ __ ] is in this
pocket of africa um the mystery of
wakanda feels like it's a thing that a
good journalist would dig into probably
working for like ebony or jet magazine
um but yeah now that's what i
that's what i'm curious about i like it
um let's see um
this ain't a sexy response but
uh the phantom stranger in dc comics
like they've never revealed his origin
alan moore did a version of him
um he kind of uh made him like uh an
iteration of the
the uh the guy who [ __ ] nails jesus
to the cross that's why he's forever
walking the earth and stuff um which was
a cool take on it but like the point of
that character was to not
[ __ ] know where he came from or what
he's about
that's definitely something you could
investigate now to be fair i haven't
read dc comics in like a long time so
i'm sure somebody's gotten around to it
but
when i back when i was reading it was
kind of left rather nebulous so i might
head in that direction
you know and there's also the i mean it
gets answered later but at some point
there was a question what happened to dr
stephen strange right like he would have
been a new york fixture he was a
celebrity doctor he was you know he held
down the residency at whatever [ __ ]
hospital he worked at and then vanished
off the face of the planet for years and
years and so the missing person of what
the [ __ ] happened to steven strange
and then this dude shows up calling
himself stephen strange who is now a
sorcerer is he the same guy is he not
like that just feels
as a journalist a question you might
want to answer
excellent point
excellent [ __ ] point like where did
bruce wayne go for nine years to learn
kung fu exactly yeah [ __ ] there's
another one man
yeah that's good why didn't that's a
good one i should have thought of that
[ __ ]
um excellent question and pretty decent
response better response from him uh
give it up that's a great question give
it up
and now
come we get to roll that oh come on over
here bring it here
we got an eight a natural eight not
eight
well done man well done
all right so
there it is
an eight at the very least you can come
and take a poster and some tickets and
then you can come back for part two all
right you're gonna come back and do all
at once you don't want to make a lot of
trips
and thank you for the [ __ ] shout out
man that's sweet never think about like
oh somebody might learn something from
this
hey man what's your name james everyone
give it up for james
um
brooklyn boy jersey very nice from
jersey
park from brooklyn but i lived in the
west uh new york and we hawking and all
that [ __ ] a um and dogma jeff's kiss
um
uh my question is a two-parter and it's
very simple
um i would like to know your opinion
on
uh william shatner going to space in a
giant penis
and it seems appropriate it seems right
and if you were george takei who has yet
to comment
uh
what would be your comment to william
shatner
do i do the voice or no
oh my
um what do i think about shatner going
to space it's absolutely adorable
and something only a [ __ ] mad
billionaire would be like hey let's
[ __ ] take captain kirk into outer
space
uh at age 90
like that's the other [ __ ] thing but
like you know i interviewed shatner
for um comic book manly and this was
like five years ago but
you know he was 85 then and you wouldn't
have known it dude looks like california
60 at best so
he's in the peak of health apparently um
you know a wonderful
idea
and it makes more sense like because
when i read that i was like you pick
shatner over mark hamill
but like you know to be fair captain
kirk was up there doing his thing
long before you know luke skywalker
showed up and to be fair
like captain kirk comes from [ __ ]
earth you know that whole story set
[ __ ] in our world where star wars is
set in frank herbert's dune apparently
so
yes captain kirk was born in indiana he
only works in space that's right so um
yeah i think it's a very very cool thing
what would uh
george takei's opinion of it be um
historically he's had some friction with
the good captain uh for for those who
are uh left out of the loop about that
um let's see you you want to go first
well i gotta still do my opinion go
ahead which is uh
good for him i guess
um but like 90 is probably the time most
people start jumping out of planes so if
captain kirk gets to go to space that's
pretty cool on a giant penis i mean
that's just an added bonus right there
the symbolism is rich
um
and i feel like george takei might be a
little bit jealous
yeah i agree jealous
or indifferent i don't know if he'd
actually want to go
has he ever expressed any interest in
like i'd really like to go to space like
my character did
no but i but i i feel like george decay
has enough of a sense of humor to say
something like
why don't i get to ride the giant dick
into outer space
yeah yeah the the tweet i guess his
comment would be forthcoming maybe he's
writing the perfect tweet for him
he's got a team of writers bruce
valanche
the first comedy minds
yeah i i can't even guess at what he
would say
um
you know
oh my
naturally
um balloon knot
or he might just go like really negative
and be like
shatner
shitner
and people like it has nothing to do
with him going to space he's like who
said it didn't
[Laughter]
um yeah i have no guess whatsoever i'm
sure he'll say something pithy and funny
though he's very good on twitter he
tweets well i can't believe he hasn't
said anything yet yeah yeah i'm telling
you it's only it must be because he's
like
like he's in a couple of drafts because
like you i bet you a lot of the world is
like and
waiting for him he's waiting for shatner
to get back safely because the last
thing you would want to do
excellent [ __ ] [ __ ] like make some
gag and then true he can't throw shade
because what a [ __ ] good captain
don't come back and people are like
you're cancelled sulu
how dare you oh that's a good point i
haven't thought of that yeah it's the
safe path that's strategic thinking
right there well done
um watch tomorrow it's like [ __ ] that
guy in space
when does that happen this trip
soon tomorrow
that's when kirk goes just the wins are
good yeah william shatner goes to space
tomorrow
and jeff bezos goes for another ride
i don't think he's on this one this one
he's not on this one
i don't know if i'd take that ride
unless he was on it i'd be like i feel a
lot safer if the guy who built this [ __ ]
was on board
they get the rest of the crew red shirts
i'm not sure what that's about
it'd be weird man if they launched it
and then [ __ ] jeff bezos got on tv
and he was like i was always a star wars
fan
i'm smart yeah you don't want to say
[ __ ] till it comes back safe i bet it's
like that uh who was it was it johnson
who had to write the the two versions of
the letters in case the apollo 13
astronauts didn't come back nixon
they're yeah 69 so there's the the
andrew from the back with the [ __ ]
deep cuts trivia well done yeah nixon 69
here's the letter if they come back
alive here's the one if they die in
space
and the the one of if they die in space
has then surfaced over the years so you
can now read the condolence letter
that you know are you know brave
american astronauts who wrote their
cherry to the gods blah blah blah blah
their their their quest for knowledge
will never be forgotten by the people
who survive them back on earth p.s
please don't sue
yeah we didn't mean it um but so yeah it
would not surprise me if there's a pair
of tweets in his drafts that are like
all right here's the good one here's the
best
that's funny good point oh my god if you
can get into george takei's
giraffes
wink
i bet you would see that very thing a
couple drafts i bet you that's a very
salty draft folder
yeah
um all right that's a great question man
[ __ ] give it up for him give it up
for james thank you james come roll
james
is that nine nine that's a nine you're
one up all right there it is man a
little bit closer
right now you're in the running for the
book james is like i don't want the
[ __ ] book
um all right here we go jc's picked
another cat
what's your name young camper uh my name
is greg greg yes greg give it up for
greg everybody
[Applause]
uh this is really cool because a few
years ago i want to say 2014 at hall h i
got one person away from asking you a
question and they shut down the lines oh
my god yeah it's a pleasure to finally
meet you um excellent to meet you man
and this is way better than like in hall
h i'm in total entertainer mode so i get
pithy answers here i give deep cuts
so you'll be able to ask and get a more
sincere answer than you ever would have
gotten from the stage at all age oh all
right um
so kind of in typical fashion i was in a
group chat discussion about anakin and
whether or not he did the right thing
joining the sith and my friend said
given the circumstances that he was left
in after revenge of the sith you know he
needed the benefits he was going to get
the best troops
like the [ __ ] rebels they didn't
offer a health plan whereas the sith
were like oh we'll rebuild your body you
know exactly um that said after the
first death star goes down and you need
to have a second death star
what benefits would you offer people to
entice them to come actually try and
work on a second death star
[Laughter]
[Applause]
without rolling dice that should win the
book
um what a wonderful question all right
how do i entice
people to come work on death star 2
after they saw what happened to death
star one number one i'm like we got rid
of the exhaust port man like
all the exhaust is inside there's no
[ __ ] tunnel for anybody to fly into
uh but the benefits i would offer
um daycare
number one yeah i mean you gotta have no
matter where you are whether it's a long
time ago in a galaxy far far away or
today
you need child care you're absolutely
right um i would also offer aside from
the usual uh health care i would offer a
uh a package that allows
what's up it's very very considerate
well done uh i would include uh an
anti-sith package uh something that
protects you
yeah but protects you from like mind
control they can't do the jedi mind
trick on you
i i feel like there would have to be a
uh that would be them telling their
employees we won't mind trick you right
similarly there would be a like you know
no force chokes in x number of days
short
you're just like 178 days no forced
jokes 178 days no force shifts like when
was the last time vader was to this
place like 178 days ago
i was real shitty about that but we got
to keep him busy elsewhere you want to
call out sick on vader days man he's
very chokey darling flex hours just in
case vader decides to show up
flexible
um uh let me see
oh [ __ ] duh
free netflix
nice that [ __ ] adds up man free free all
the app channels i mean you'd get disney
plus
that shit's free yeah i guess but i
would offer if i'm the empire i'd offer
a full package i'd be like we'll give
you free netflix
amazon prime hbo max disney plus [ __ ]
even peacock which is [ __ ] free like
we'll give you everything because that
like think about how much money you
would save if somebody was spending i
saw a thing
like uh on a like on the internet about
like [ __ ] jobs wanted or whatever
maybe it was on
seth myers or something on a closer look
but there was an image of uh like a sign
you know where
right now people are quitting jobs like
crazy and there's so many job openings
the most in history or whatever the [ __ ]
one of the signs like offered like you
know [ __ ] big salary and free netflix
that really captured my imagination
where i was like would that be the
difference for somebody
like it would be for me if i walked in
and they're like [ __ ] you know
there's all this [ __ ]
plus you get free netflix i'd be like
i'll [ __ ] work here oh my god no like
well it's netflix so [ __ ] go ahead
it's free you won't even get to watch it
because you're busy building a death
star but sure
i mean you don't build the death star
all the time they never really indicated
that they were like horrible bosses i
mean other than the fact that they were
evil but like not bad to their employees
like hey man we need you to work [ __ ]
16 hours today you would think because
vader shows up in return of the jedi
he's like you're way behind schedule man
and he's like i'll fix it i'll fix it
they had to be giving like a lot of time
off like weekends on endor like all
right all sorts of stuff because they
were so behind schedule there's
something to that question there's like
real thought behind the benefits of the
second death star like i completely
believe that there's like you know
employee retreats on indoor like you get
a tree house you get your own [ __ ]
tree house that you can go to
and just spend [ __ ] weekends and [ __ ]
will you enjoy endor does a bear [ __ ] in
the woods
have you seen these woods nothing but
beers
um yeah man you'd have to make some
pretty
healthy promises i mean it's [ __ ] i
hadn't thought about that how do you get
people to come back when they feel like
i saw it blow up
like you're doing it again
that's the thing they just heard about
it like maybe nobody heard like it's a
[ __ ] it's a space station blowing up
like
thousands of parsecs away and you're in
the outer rim you're just [ __ ]
chilling in in mandalorian though cobb
vance timothy oliphant watches it blow
up on the holonet i guess that's the
return of the jedi death star but you
would think that
they all watched it like it was on the
news how do you not see that yeah i mean
like at the very least
they're like i don't know if you knew
this but there was a space station
man-made space station as big as a
[ __ ] moon that's no moon it was a
[ __ ] and then
someone blew it up a bunch of [ __ ]
rebels blew it the [ __ ] up so none of us
got to enjoy it like [ __ ] the rebels
listen the empire is 100 saying that
that [ __ ] was fake news yeah there was
no cameras there this is the [ __ ]
rebels who say they blew mistake what
are the odds
that those [ __ ] knuckleheads blew up
our space station the size of a small
moon didn't [ __ ] do that well where'd
it go it was repo'ed and so
it's in the shop we had some the exhaust
port was [ __ ] and so we had to get
that fixed
like it's a [ __ ] it's a moon so it's
you just can't see it it's it but you'll
see it again and then they'll like quick
build another one fast
we got egg on our face and you could
really see it yeah i mean the the sort
of propaganda department of the empire
would have put out the story that that's
fine
it's okay we're just getting the the
paint done we're tinting the windows so
it's gonna be out for a bit
i just don't know the widespread
knowledge of the blowing up of the death
star outside of the rebel alliance i
think that kind of news travels
everywhere man
like that's huge huge news huge on so
many fronts
what
how'd they get a second loan exactly
they're not they don't need a loan they
like disney they got all that money and
[ __ ] like scrooge mcduck gold coins
and [ __ ] yeah they just added like 10
bucks to the admission to the empire
theme park
and then they just built another one
that is fascinating so i mean that
sounds like something should have been
in the kevin smith movie i stopped with
like the [ __ ] uh first death star
really didn't i wait first death star
blowed up evil's punished the second
death star i mean there were independent
contractors
how the [ __ ] did i miss that man
you really should have taken the
discussion one step further and be like
how do you even get people to come back
for that [ __ ] job what are you
offering them
deep cuts yeah all i could come up for
the stormtroopers was a nice suit and a
quick death that's true man i feel like
there's you would have to offer me
[ __ ] sex to get me onto the
death star too there's an oral hygiene
plan and an oral sex plan yeah really
both of which you get like let's do this
you'll get blown for the rest of your
life but to be fair the rest of your
life might be short if you work on a
death star
have you ever been force choked well but
have you though
[Laughter]
you know what are they aren't they doing
what is the
show they're doing right now on disney
plus
visions so it's about like [ __ ]
alternate star wars stories and they're
quick hits right very fast
can i pitch one i mean if you can do it
anime yeah you can alright disney plus
here's my star wars just visions that's
what it's called
uh
[ __ ] you know i i generally they
don't do the big characters but can i
play with some big characters they do
job of the hut so they've he's the
biggest character they got
literally
in my little star wars vision
uh
there's a you know a [ __ ] familiar
scene darth vader on the [ __ ] uh the
deck of a star destroyer
and uh you know somebody [ __ ] up
and so vader [ __ ] force chokes him
and the guy knows he's gonna die
so he quick jerks off
tell me
tell me people wouldn't start
subscribing even more to disney plus if
they're like have you seen the latest
star wars v it's a vision all right
there's a guy that jerks off right
before he dies and then it would cause a
lot of discussion people would be like
why did star wars do this but also some
people would be like what a good idea if
i'm ever going to die i'm going to jerk
off right at the end because it'll
really confuse your killer because you
could cut to darth vader being like what
the [ __ ]
so for a moment he stops but then he's
like ah [ __ ] it and then he chokes him
again and [ __ ] i just want to see what
happens he's like i can't believe he
likes it [ __ ] yeah i like scrolling
through visions i get this one's 18
minutes long this is 22 minutes this is
two and a half minutes
what's this one the shortest vision of
all time
oh vader my lack of faith is disturbing
do it
do it you son of a [ __ ] he's like
that's what i wanted
i wanted you to do it all right
and everyone on the [ __ ] and all of a
sudden they look at vader differently
like he ain't so bad
you know because that guy got one over
on him and [ __ ] and even better
if you
if if he's killing you and you're
defiantly jerking off adam as you die
there's a good chance you're gonna leave
a mark on that black suit ahead ah
and i don't know if you know this but
it's tough to [ __ ] get [ __ ] out of
leather
you have to buff it out for a while like
there's there's a dude down there he's
like it's all over my cape
[ __ ] jerk the [ __ ] nobody else do
that if i choke you
you get one don't choke me i'm gonna
choke you don't do it i'll [ __ ] grab
my dick like the last guy right here i
dare you i double dog dare you [ __ ]
choke me see what happens like i thought
i had some [ __ ] with a rebellion man
[ __ ] this is a rebellion right on my
[ __ ]
deck i can't even say anything to these
fools anymore
the coffee's a little [ __ ] cold
anybody notice that you son of a [ __ ]
just don't [ __ ] come at me hey
emperor i got a problem i got a whole
[ __ ] death star full of wank happy
morons and i want to choke him i really
want to [ __ ] choke him but every time
i do i look at my suit
so i walked under a tree full of people
jerking off emperor they found my
kryptonite
they know how afraid i am of getting [ __ ]
don and the emperor's like you think you
got problems i just found out i was in
frank herbert's dude
um that was an excellent question give
it up for that question
let's see
how we roll
oh just real quick um i wanted to say
thank you for wait did we both answer or
no oh it was a whole lot of answers yeah
yeah
it was so long i forgot i thought maybe
i just cut you off it's like mark what
are you gonna do
i just wanted to say thank you for
giving the ideas of be a why not person
and
uh don't curse the darkness when you
could light a
well i stole that from the from the coen
brothers it's in in it's in raising
arizona uh john uh john goodman's
character goes uh but i'd rather light a
candle than curse your darkness h.i
so yeah i've always kind of loved that
phrase uh why you know
don't curse the darkness light a candle
but especially the why not makes me a
better person and i i feel like i'm
enjoying my life a lot more so thank you
[ __ ] hey thank you for that
[Applause]
you got 11 numbers that'll win this for
you
[Applause]
oh
his name is a killing word [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] indeed man where are you going
we're going don't run away
take posters and take tickets those are
all yours you won you're a [ __ ] huge
winner
the book too
that's yes that's the book i brought
um it is heavy you could kill a [ __ ]
that's right show it to the camera thank
you so much for the plug
please don't [ __ ] hurt anybody with
the book i'm so
scared that it's gonna show up on the
internet this book hurts somebody it's
so [ __ ] heavy um where are the two
players man
come pick up your prizes for heaven's
sakes give it up for our winners our
question askers
are winners
and give it up for who had this
who had the big ass [ __ ] die the
bar's got it
the bar has it
thank you
it's [ __ ] awesome more of this man
the point i just looked around and
remembered um
all right i signed a bunch of [ __ ] um
and then we talk is this meant to be
signed is that why it's here is that
right
to my favorite captain america
to adam your favorite favorite captain
america
um i'll do that and mark will talk in
the meantime so it's not awkward for
everybody
well come on it's not a good t just
[ __ ] talk
i mean that's all we do on this [ __ ]
show i know and the one time i'm like i
need you to talk you're like what do you
want me to just [ __ ] talk
i'm sure you got some [ __ ] to say i uh
how about oh look banff man is here to
rescue you i'll fill in some uh some
chatter from the internet
oh that's always good i should have
turned to you man i was going to sing a
seashaney but if you wanna
what uh what is the internet saying did
the chat room come back or chat um yeah
chat came back uh a lot of chat came
back it wouldn't stay away it was home
sweet home the very next day
we had uh we had a lot of love for scott
we had some people in the chat who took
his class and said it was phenomenal we
had some people who listened to him
talked tonight and was like oh i got to
take this guy's class so that was pretty
cool how can i man he was worth it for
scott to stay up well done
um we had a bunch of people wanting mark
to talk about midnight mass as a
follow-up to the black man beyond did
you uh watch midnight mass ah no
so i can't but i will because i wanna i
gotta support rahul he he showed up and
he showed out and he he gave very good
content and also i like his work and i i
like mike flanagan's work so yeah i'm
going to give it a go but i had to squid
game at first so now i'm going to
midnight
we uh and then we had my favorite
comment was from actual dracula
he said uh i came for scott snyder and
apparently stayed for the native
deodorant
oh
[ __ ] hey well done man we thank our
sponsor native deodorant for
backing our silliness tonight although
it sounds like people got some something
out of the show other than the normal
[ __ ] that's what happens when you got a
good guest like scott god he's got
comics in his [ __ ] he bleeds four
colors doesn't he no just [ __ ] really
comics through and through there's a guy
who gives a [ __ ] about the industry and
[ __ ] wants kids to come back so nice
most people are profiteering and trying
to turn everything into a [ __ ] movie
this guy's literally thinking about the
industry that's given him everything um
good for good for good for scott and
good for all of us
for people like scott
yeah yeah give it up one more time for
scott snyder
he's going
that's a good [ __ ] he's going to make
me look into that comicsology thing i
feel like you should that's what's so
weird i stand next to a guy who's been
talking about it it's okay just take his
word for it that smart guy said
something mark quiet i can't hear him um
that sounds like a pretty sweet deal
um well there it is kids uh don't forget
um
you got anything to sell
uh i don't really scott [ __ ] snyder
sold my book better than i have so no
yes if you're on the comixology if you
take advantage of his deal and take part
in scott tober then also take a look at
a door in the distance you'll get it in
there for free the um uh that book that
we gave away kevin smith secret stash
available right now on amazon or you can
go to inside editions they're the good
folks that made the book and they're
doing a big fat boxed set version of it
as a puzzle and stuff like that looks
like the viewskew bible that alanis held
at the end of jane sambov checked back
very very cool
um thanks to the good folks at inside
editions uh for for uh making that book
in the first place especially chris
prince we had a signing last
monday tuesday or something like that uh
at uh the chinese theater and it was
absolutely lovely event
folks came out we did q a and i read
from the book as well it was really
really fun man so thanks to everybody
who came out for that i'm heading to
jersey the weekend of october 22nd
uh to do the same thing at the secret
stash we have a book signing on the 24th
it's all sold out before that though
however ladies and gentlemen on the 23rd
if you're in the philadelphia area or
the tri-state area at all um the
philadelphia film festival is showing
clerk uh malcolm ingram's documentary
about uh me and my wife and my work and
stuff uh so tickets are available right
now at sea smart and then me and malcolm
go out on tour mini tour with
clerk we go to austin st louis chicago
vancouver toronto i believe jersey as
well uh so if you're interested in the
live show that's me and malcolm coming
out and q a and afterwards and whatnot
after you see the movie uh tickets at
csmodd.com
right now um don't forget master the
universe of revelation coming november
23rd
so right in time for thanksgiving man
[ __ ] eat your turkey and [ __ ]
watch skeletor wreck [ __ ]
um and uh are we back next week
uh maybe we can be should we do it we
haven't thought about it
as uh i like about this show it's very
decisive yeah
maybe
that's true but that's honestly what i
like about the show is how loosey-goosey
it is i always get nerv not nervous but
like a little like uh-oh when we do like
tonight we had scott on who's absolutely
lovely but scott's back east
waiting to go on the [ __ ] show
and you know the show never begins a on
time or b with any format that like
resembles something that would be user
friendly to the first guest
so you know going into it it's always
like oh man we're gonna be thrown off
like the [ __ ] what we do and stuff
but he was so [ __ ] great and so
gracious to stay up as late as he did
and uh talk with as much heart as he did
so um this show tonight for me was
insanely helpful as well because uh i
was thinking about breaking my fast but
uh now i'll easily cruise into tomorrow
because i was sitting here with y'all
man you kept me
preoccupied from thinking about [ __ ]
eating and stuff like that so
if anybody got anything out useful out
of the show tonight uh thank you
congrats but i got something very
[ __ ] useful out of the show tonight
as i always do uh there is no show
ladies and gentlemen uh without our home
here at the scum and villainy cantina
ran by banff man himself jc
[Applause]
and there literally is no show unless
there's somebody standing here
correcting me and [ __ ] coming up with
better ideas and asking more insightful
questions and [ __ ] like that
give it up for my uh co-host the
marvelous mark bernard and ladies and
gentlemen
thank you sir
we thank uh scott snyder for popping in
and being our guest uh we thank
everybody uh for coming out tonight and
and uh playing and stuff so nice to be
in front of people again to be doing a
live show yeah in many ways not just
like the hey we get to talk about fun
stuff but just the trickle down for me
is is enormous um it helps uh keep me in
line so to speak in as much as i'm like
i'm be on camera i can't just [ __ ]
eat everything that i want to eat so
it's good this good this show is not
just fun to do but [ __ ] therapeutic
as hell for me jc's yawning so it's time
to [ __ ] go
dude with a baby oh my god uh that
ladies and gentlemen is fat man beyond
for this week
i'm kevin smith i am mark bernard tune
in next week same fat time same fat
channel smartcast.com or youtube.com
kevin smith jeff's kiss wow
[Applause]
you